two what up
okay
what up
Troopers Nation yes
what a big pimps what a big pimps
it's Friday baby oh
October 14th Halloween's coming right up
here pretty soon eh
all the kids are happy Theodore is so
excited
everybody knows Halloween when it comes
to kids is by far the best holiday
birthdays Christmas maybe is dope but
Halloween Just
and I've Loved kids when I'm allowed
yeah you know I mean candy is currency
to kids like oh yeah it's our son and
our house it is yeah it's literally it's
all he cares about it's the only meaning
he has in life if you literally you
could literally spend it like money with
kids there's people just spending as
they just hand out money
Halloween
thank you to our sponsors our wonderful
sponsors gamer sup rise up
rise up
[Applause]
we love gamer Subs
cribe
I love that I'm hitting that black
cherry flavor you know what they know
about it
and that's the flavor you like the black
cherry one too yeah and and also
sponsored by hellofresh we love them
don't we folks how's everybody doing on
this beautiful Friday what's up Tick
Tock what's up tater tots my boys my
gals
shut up okay all right we're doing great
I'm sorry I thought you're trying to
tick tock we're doing lovely we're
having I was [ __ ] blast dude
oh my God we have actually really fun
special episode planned today um
Ian and Sam young
Samantha Young Samantha yeah you
remember who I am yes I even Flex with
your full God uh my government name yeah
you guys went to a wax museum
and we're inspired by how bad it looked
is that right Zach two and oh Zach right
yeah I was there for moral support yeah
and uh so you guys went there filmed a
segment and then the result of that yeah
was that each one of these beautiful
crew members has
attempted to cast my face into wax
really except
it's Clay Not wax
but okay clay I like it whatever it's
all sculpted yeah we made some busts
we're getting busty up in this office in
the last couple days that's right we
getting busty we should call it Bust or
busted
something's about to busting or busted
something is about buzzed we spent over
like four hours on these things so a lot
of work well yeah I would come into the
office and then they would clean up and
put it away and there was like a whole
arts and craft it was like something
that's something that's nice so you guys
had fun with it yeah it was like summer
camp Sam was the was the art teacher
Miss Temple Miss Temple yeah
I had to ask to go to the bathroom they
were raising their hand to ask questions
um I wonder if any of them are gonna
look for anything like me but we'll see
how hard it is to make a piece of clay
look like somebody you know yeah not for
us easy all right are you gonna see
we'll see about that they came out
pretty good well the winner actually
we're gonna choose to sell on our
website for 500 like Jordan Peterson's
bust right
and we'll call it the father of
knowledge uh and lobsters I don't know
up yours up yours well moralist
I'm so tired today man hit that Subs
dude what are you doing chug chug chug
chug
do it do it
yeah boy
you're sleeping water while you're
waking up people are asking for a fake
check
oh yeah go ahead just go ahead let me
start with I got inspired this week
new shirt
explain the Lord explain the Lord okay
um well you know go ahead to unpack it
little Stevie boy there's a little
message out to you Steve will do it
who said he'd rather [ __ ] Jeffrey Dahmer
than Ela which uh I think is something
we need to unpack there yeah there's a
lot to him yeah
there's a lot but actually Ela you made
this shirt out of your league yeah
and this is an official Teddy fresh
shirt right this is coming out soon it
will be
Steve
in your dreams bro
even Jeffrey Dahmer's out of your league
let's be real nah he's not he [ __ ] your
heart Jeffrey dahmers bro Jeff Thomas
yeah dommers
I wish Jeffrey Dahmer would use my heart
like a flush light bro
that's what he thinks I mean that's what
yeah it's pretty
graphic a little too graphic this
morning this afternoon
well show off the rest
um and then yeah the rest is just
whatever no stop
I'll first play it later pictures yeah
we need to fit checks on the brand
and the hair and makeup fire yeah the
hair okay so thank you I'm trying I love
it I think we should we should do like a
like a little get ready with us before
every Friday it's like so scary because
I don't do makeup during the week like
maybe a light slight like tinted kind of
you know moisturizer stuff but on Friday
I feel like I want to do it and then I'm
like but why it's kind of a bad idea to
try something for the first time like
right before the show so like I'd like
to know that you did I tried like
eyeshadow like I have no idea what I'm
doing it looks really good you know Ela
never wore makeup ever by our whole time
uh together yeah so it's a new thing
Steve of course tweeted out
um yesterday not about you oh whoever
bought Jeffrey Dahmer's glasses for 150k
I'll pay 200 for them the obsession is a
little weird now is it gonna pay with
his own mind
what are you gonna do put him on Donnie
as you jerk them off
weirdo
thinking about Donnie and Dahmer well
Donnie and Dahmer kind of Cooler
example when I jerk off Donnie is this
the face he makes when he's jerking off
Donnie and watching Disney cartoons
Donnie Donnie bro you look like
yeah my mic was muted I said it looks
like he was watching porn accidentally
opened his camera
that's funny take some photos
like a blob of silly putty bruh
your ass is silly buddy
I just find it endlessly incredible this
man called you ugly and I'm not one to
call people ugly ever I would never say
that about someone all people are
beautiful but he's a beast
he's a [ __ ] beast I think once
someone opens fire like that they allow
it yeah yeah I kind of think so too yeah
yeah yeah oh and by the way these are my
friends not yours loser
why are Dan is better I have no idea
yeah so anyway
um we are
what what's the deal with this dress by
the way you can't wash it this morning
we were talking about it I don't know
you can't what's is it like special
it's like
a Saturn
I can't wash it no you can't even clean
dry it that's apparently
apparently what the care label said I'm
not sure what are you supposed to just
throw it out one time yes just don't get
dirty don't get dirty I guess some
clothes is like that right just pray
just wear it and pray yeah
I mean what happens if you dry clean it
what's the worst that could happen
I don't think anything would happen
personally
just disintegrate they make it sound so
serious
um anyway I do want to say
actually quickly here at the top there
we had like a second drop of Teddy fresh
drop here I just want to give a quick
shout out teddyfirst.com it was part of
the October drop and a few pieces came
afterwards I'm wearing one of them this
is actually in collaboration with a
really talented
um yeah fantastic artist jump rope on
Instagram wait how come is it show me
can we link to them on the website or I
mentioned his name here we can uh we're
gonna post about it on Instagram and tag
him bro what's his name
jump rope jump rope
well I guess we just commissioned the
design remember yeah it looks dope we
don't always share the people who make
the graphic Cameron's rocking that one
right there that you were just looking
at yeah I'm wearing this one really nice
um
and then finally the then the flower
denims that I know people have been
waiting forever so finally the jacket is
back and then this time overalls and a
short sleeve shirt this is definitely a
favorite yeah of the folks everybody
loves this jacket is this shirt new oh
my God this shirt is fire Zach you look
so good in this shirt thank you I love
this shirt it's great material I'm like
wait I need one of these yeah can you
hook me up one of these Lena
yeah I can do that I think I need a 2XL
this one though I went down to XL since
I lost a bit of weight but I'm thinking
I might need a
a denim shirt's not going to be very
forgiving I think
and um
oh these are really cool puffy cozy
quilty yes teddy bear quilted oh
Olivia's rocking that I'm just rocking
that yeah the actually stitching is
super cool it's teddy bear yeah oh and
Lena's rocking overalls I just realized
oh let me see oh yeah
yeah yeah our overall's back yeah
overalls are [ __ ] Lena just brought him
back
one single-handedly brought him back
so slay I think that's that's it of the
new stuff here
so
check it out you know what I mean the
necklace it came out last week
oh which one oh those are so cute this
one oh the necklace sold out yeah oh
okay
rib I think we might restock it there it
is
um
so actually
before you bring up Gabe I do just want
to say uh
sadly a friend of the show
dear Tony
[Music]
yeah maybe
this might be a little hard to pull off
with Gabe yeah no no no I just I just uh
he's muted for now I'm not sure if [ __ ]
baby Woos is the best yeah no
inappropriate during uh well
he has pulled it off in the past
Gabe Tony by the way uh a friend of the
show a great guy
um
a total sweetheart
I crossed paths with them the first time
when we were doing our keemstar series
he was the guy that came accused of uh
being a p word pedo
wrongly what it was like completely out
of [ __ ] nowhere
anyway it's not about keemstar at all
but
I crossed paths with him and uh we
sparked up a bit of a friendship and um
he was a legendary RuneScape player
but that man
and uh well he he passed away uh today
to cancer unfortunately and uh he will
be missed he was a great guy and uh a
friend of the show
and uh
gone here today this is his nephew who
he worked with just basically announcing
it and
it's quite sad and I just wish him his
family and everyone uh
comfort and peace at this time
so long live uh RS glory and gold yeah
Tony
the legend
that guy's such an interesting character
to be honest like first of all to
dedicate your life to playing RuneScape
that's already a dub
foreign
you know what I mean like this man was
true to his hobby all the way through
you've got to love that
I can only dream to be [ __ ] like
streaming on Twitch with a crown
playing World of Warcraft or some [ __ ]
you know that'll be the equivalent when
I'm old
EverQuest EverQuest yeah
yeah Tony was a funny guy
a good guy a strong man he passed at 69
and uh
well we wish them well or we wish the
family well I mean and we wish him
rest in peace there uh good old Tony
all right Gabe let's see what he has to
say about this how the transition one
second
there's a test right now it's [ __ ]
game [ __ ] Gabe what happened
[ __ ] Yankees are they blowing it I
gave up a [ __ ] run to [ __ ]
Cleveland oh no
but it's [ __ ] but it's Friday
wait yeah who's yelling can you flip can
you flip the camera I want to see what's
going on
who's angry who's yelling
everybody's angry they can score a run
[ __ ]
what's the score oh it's his
brother-in-law
did he just lose a bunch of money
whatever what's happening he's can we
talk to him or is that off off the
is that is that no yeah I don't know if
we could say hi or if that's no off
limits
that's uh
yeah
he's having fun right now he just seems
stupid little upset
does he usually get that angry when he
plays Gabe or when he watches of course
yeah of course of course everybody gets
everybody
right I feel the same way my [ __ ]
team lose [ __ ] [ __ ] so did they
lose or is it over they just lost the
point where star what what's we're lucky
we're tied two and two okay so we're not
don't [ __ ] it up Yankees
yes yes
[Applause]
wait what just happened
they closed the inning yeah
we did it the Yankees closed the ending
we did it everyone I'll be honest so
Gabe the Yankees are coming what inning
is it
[Music]
so what inning is this yeah
bottom on the bottom of the knife
that's the last inning okay and the
Yankees are at bat so they can close it
up right now Gabe I kind of don't want
to hang up I want to see what goes down
over there
we represent New York what the [ __ ] West
New York [ __ ] you're in the
wrong City Punk
is it
well that's one thing I got I don't I'm
not into sports but man people get so
fired up about that stuff like my dad
used to yeah can't scream at the TV like
that and I was like why are you doing
this why are you watching this why are
you doing this Dodger games are intense
man baseball is and my my dad didn't
even do sports betting like I get it if
you're invested or some should and but
my my dad was just
you really didn't care about me hear
more about the Dodgers than me I'll be
honest that's how you feel too Gabe
that's how I feel like when my team
loses I'm like frustrated I
know anybody else my [ __ ] team lead
right [ __ ]
but Gabe you have no control over the
outcome of the game do you find that uh
at odds at all
well it's it's true but it's like it's
just like the feeling you know you
you're upset you know you made the wrong
decisions you made the wrong decisions
you know you can't control it right
hey cam how do you feel about the
Yankees I don't want to comment on it
how do you feel about the Yankees we're
[ __ ] hate the Yankees
I'm not mad I like I like your honest
opinion that's what matters
do you wanna do you want to shoot on the
the Red Sox you can shoot on the Red Sox
if you want
can you do me a favor ask Nick Nick's
dad what he thinks about the Red Sox
hey what do you think about the
okay oh [ __ ] okay yeah yeah he's he's in
the zone yeah he's focused
he is Die Hard Yankee fan like it's
insane this is big this is his whole
week his whole month culminating here is
it playoffs or something yeah we're
imposes it's the playoffs okay so it's a
little something's on the line here we
go all right tell me what happens
okay here we go
[Music]
[ __ ] strike one oh [ __ ] can we watch the
whole game like this
is there like a IP issue here with uh
Gabe announcing the game live for us no
no as long as we don't show footage from
it it's fine he's our Vince Scully all
right yeah right here we go here we go
here we go here we go
okay
ball one
ball one strike
let's just do this one at bat at least
okay all right oh my God
let's just quiet now just hold on it's
coming I just want to hear what the room
oh [ __ ] I love hearing
all right [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what
happened Gabe strike three no [ __ ] oh a
[ __ ] hey what they already got it out
[ __ ] wait we gotta find out the next one
now if it's already one strike [ __ ]
okay wait
Gabe what's happening all right Gabe
what's happening
everyone focused
here we go that's Focus I think it
wasn't three strikes maybe two strikes
here we go
I can only imagine no it's probably
about the pitch
intense moment there you go yeah
don't fight
don't bite don't bite don't judge just
go judge that's good is that the guy's
name Aaron judge he's the big hitter
right yeah yeah
um
focus focus everyone everyone in the
audience focus in the chat focus focus
focus come on baby
come on [ __ ] give me a good one
give me a good one give me a good word
oh okay
what happened Gabe
Gabe tell us what happened
there's 30 000 people waiting for you to
update us
okay
here we go they're still pitching what's
happening Gabe
okay so we got on base
not yet not yet not yet okay okay
come on Aaron hold it together everyone
thank you
okay that's okay that's okay that's okay
that's okay that's it so it seems like
you got two strikes three bats which
means it's all happening now well they
could walk him they could walk him
this is the best hitter can't give up a
homer I guess so you're a savior let's
do a savior judge
good job
okay all right
all right damn this is the long at back
brother that's why I was trying to warn
you oh we're sticking through it though
that's the best commentator but it's
like I checked we think otherwise no
you're wrong about that so you're giving
us everything all right so so just if
you could describe what the pitcher's
doing
another foul
damn all right baseball's boring dude
okay we're gonna chant ready yes
[Music]
all right here we go
[Music]
you guys can give me good luck come on
we're moving for him come on Judge
one out damn oh he's out he's out he's
out
what do we want something
I had twenty thousand dollars spreading
on this game what happened did he strike
he struck out I'm pissing my ass
he crowned out he ground out what a
[ __ ] idiot
[ __ ]
so should we watch the next one what are
you gonna do I'm very very important we
need to wrap this up are you sure I do I
do
it's been a pleasure no stand let's do a
poll the people
Rizzo's up Dan okay should we should we
yeah around for rizzos you gotta be one
strike I mean things are not bad yeah is
that the poll should we stick around for
rizzos at bat yes yes okay yes yes no
this is boring as [ __ ] hang up who would
say that
bad poll Anthony Rizzo's good he could
hit it
favorite today yeah all right last one
we'll just watch this one last swing and
then we'll we'll say our farewells to
Gabe
here we go
quiet guys please
[Music]
I like Focus I want to hear the room I
want to hear what's going on there
okay
try
[ __ ] wow [ __ ] we have uh the yeses have
it but I will point out yeses have it
but 41 of our audience is saying this is
boring as [ __ ] hang up oh really
so well was that the no option yeah well
that's a bad pull Dan 59 you literally
did a bad poll bro
oh
[Applause]
guys I'm bored [ __ ] [ __ ] oh you
know what let's do this let's do this
a b you keep an eye in the game and when
there's a point scored let's get Gabe
back on the phone immediately because I
want to feel the energy in that room
okay you got it Gabe if there's a point
you call us back okay call us back
immediately all right all right all
right thanks buddy good luck to the
Yankees out there okay go yucky
you [ __ ] [ __ ] my dick hole [ __ ] get
me a dick hole [ __ ]
yeah wait no damn
give me pink eye [ __ ] boy
[ __ ] [ __ ] stick my poop inside
my ear and my nose baby
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] out that's
two outs that's two odds we gotta stay
for the third man oh my god dude
shave off my pubes and put them on my
face [ __ ]
shaved up pewter put on my I think my
hairy face [ __ ]
do they gonna do they get annoyed that
you're not taking it seriously is your
family okay with this
it's all right it's supposed to be they
know me
every ass lick my hairy [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah that's good
hairy ass baby shave it off baby feels
good
I love the idea of
the dude taking it so seriously
hey Gabe just lick my [ __ ] [ __ ]
look my baby
hey shove my balls up my own [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah shove my shove the balls in my ass
baby
yeah hey put your balls to my eyes and
just leave them there like a [ __ ]
coaster baby
yeah yeah off in my eyes [ __ ] my eyes
oh how about this one use use my heart
like a fleshlight dobber
uh I don't know about that one maybe
that one's too wow
yeah this might be our longest game call
by the way probably interesting universe
that's the thing about Friday you just
never know you never know we're at 18
minutes it's really been going eight
years huh yes sir in fact we're almost
at break time we almost did the whole
inning yep so what's going on on the
game should we say goodbye or what's
happening
well
well yeah so so is there someone else a
bat there it's two outs what's going on
uh oh so it's the next inning oh oh they
lost they lost we're in the tenth now
yeah okay it's it's a that's enough all
right good good luck Yankees all right
Gabe all right
milk mine male nipples
[Music]
yeah nipples baby [ __ ] baby suck on my
titties suck on my titties [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right
for sure yep all right love you Gabe all
right luck good luck Yankees all right
wow intense out there those sports fans
are serious serious yeah
I'm a little bit jealous of sports fans
because I admire that passion that how
with how much they care about their
sport I'd like to have something like
that in my life but I just can't bring
myself to care
that you're not into it because I think
it's bad for marriages oh yeah Sports is
definitely bad for marriages it's ruined
many a family I'm with you though Ethan
I've always wondered how people could
feel so involved when they're not
playing themselves I mean I wish I could
get so excited but yeah it's like I mean
you're and sorry I'm sorry not to demean
sports fans experiences but it's like
you're literally just betting on a coin
toss I mean you're just passively
watching
right but okay you know whatever it's
it's the athleticism is amazing these
people these people are great at what
they do
Jay's musings uh thank you for the gift
it said reflecting on Steve will jerkat
and others I think you are dead on
you've achieved more success including
an amazing relationship in a way that is
completely antithetical to the methods
they live by and promote brains crash
and go fat equals bad
yeah that's kind of something that I was
thinking is when Steve he was insulting
you but he seemed so angry and so
obviously he's angry at me
and I I really think he's angry at you
for marrying me because he he doesn't he
thinks Maybe
I just shouldn't exist
no but he the women are an extent women
are like a Rolex to Steve who literally
basically said that yeah yeah I'm like
so and his worldview I'm like a Casio
like with a calculator well that's a
fire watch I think it's fire but he
would be like what is this dorky us
right watch like an Apple Watch with an
orange strap
my point is is that he's angry at you
for marrying me because in his worldview
someone like me should be alone and
broke and he's so angry that I'm not so
he blames you he says you need to be
going after high value men like him
because he will do it role model I don't
think that's what he was saying I'm just
I'm trying to
make some sense out of that beautiful
mind of his angry yeah
I think he's also angry maybe that I
said that like if the if the cat dog
thing was a joke then like it wasn't
funny like if
trying to be funny then start by being
funny which was the point I made last
time and I think maybe he got mad at
that and also I said that Bradley has
the bigger ties that's what it was what
break Bradley's facts dude Bradley is
stacked in the thigh apartment
uh we had one more from Okie I had to
say goodbye to my sweet boy
and uh his doggy oh no
yeah I'm sorry about that man I was
thinking about
I want to bring the show down but
since Jeff's dog passed away and he told
me about that I've been thinking about
you know yeah the unthinkable the
unthinkable with Arlo I was it's just
it's not enough you just don't have
enough time with them it's just not fair
anyway
um so wow that was a long Gabe thing let
me catch up where are we uh we are at um
our sponsor time this is where we're at
so let's thank our sponsors and then
we'll we'll have ela's official response
to Steve will Jerk It calling you ugly
um and uh well and a lot more and that
I'm excited about the the boss segment
too coming up so let's thank Gamers sup
man I love these guys actually I have
something uh uh that you had noted you
wanted to uh shout out on our next uh
gamer Subs ad I just sent it to you
I saw this post on the subred it cracked
me up I thought gamer sup was something
the crew made up to make fun of Jesus oh
like an inside joke I didn't know it was
an actual company you better believe it
that would be so funny though real as it
gets I probably would have named it
something crazier than that gamer so
gamer goo
no gamer sub's real and it's delicious
and I absolutely love this drink I'll be
honest with you this drink has changed
my podcasting game I'm more energized
and I used to always get so drowsy on
the way all right and I I have not
gotten drowsy once right since I started
hitting that black chair Gamer sucks
I also used to not know what to drink
like sometimes I drink coffee and it's
like just not a good drink during the
show it gets cold it kind of makes you
feel gross yeah the Shaker is great You
bit up with ice you got a refreshing
basically tasty water with some caffeine
in it black cherries mine
I'm hitting that mango today oh I
haven't tried them I hadn't tried until
today either uh that one's good I'm top
tier yeah yeah I'm having pina colada I
try this at the witchcon booth for gamer
Subs really good I haven't tried pina
colada I want to try that one it's good
black cherry every time so good that's
it
are you loyal to the lemonade Lena I
noticed you were drinking that last time
yeah this is the one I have all the time
it's my favorite that's interesting they
have so many flavors it's actually
pretty fun to try them and find out yeah
I like it really cool it's like you
remember when Harry and and Harry Potter
how they choose their wands and it bonds
with them it's like that gamer stuff
when you find your flavor you know
yeah gamer stops our new partner
they recently gave out over ten thousand
uh to fupert Troopers a chance to fry
try their product for free Gamers up is
the healthiest and best tasting
alternate alternative to energy drinks
and soda I just gotta flashback to
Arkansas
and documentary
you missed our Kansas
I thought you were pain I was confused
for a second what bro it was so messed
up somebody just said my Gamers have
arrived for free and freaking South
Africa shout out Sarah
sugar sucks and it's terrible for you
you know you don't want to drink sugary
drinks it's honestly a thing of the past
it's just not the way you're gonna gain
weight you're gonna increase your risk
of heart disease and you're gonna get
acne apparently so who owns that
[ __ ] weight gain and heart disease just
don't just don't give me acne
but enjoy getting an energized boost to
your day by simply throwing Two Scoops
into a shaker cup or water bottle it's
that simple boom
do I guess I mean we can show you guys
but it's really
boom boom
simply just explain uh oh this this is a
meta copy here yeah it's it's great
I think I've made that clear
35 cents per serving
a lot of people use this uh as a
catalyst to becoming healthy and
eliminating sugary beverages
you know sure I never had that life hack
where I just there's a lot of people
that fatties who drink soda and stuff
and like juice
I never really got down with that stuff
like sugar actual sugar yeah yeah like
just the original Coke
yeah and they lose these people that are
on that [ __ ] they lose so much weight by
cutting out the sugary drinks
in my opinion you kind of have to be a
psychopath to regularly drink a regular
Coke
I I don't know I mean no offense but
there's like 50 grams of sugar I mean
it's nuts but that's [ __ ] good I know
it tastes great but Coke Zero tastes
pretty much yeah Coke Zero is a good
drink but we're not talking about
cookies they're gonna taste better
gamer Subs game this is a whole
different category of beverages someone
in Chad asked if they have caffeine free
options and they yeah they do actually
yes
they have they actually sent us a
caffeine-free options and then you're
just getting a nice little like
a little beverage nice little Bev there
yeah
zero sugar zero calories 100 milligrams
of organic coffee uh
uh and it has a coffee free option
here's where it gets good use code H3
and you'll get 10 off your whole order
boom
if you want to see a H3 Shaker or flavor
in the future
go support
oh no
an H3 flavor and shaker you want to see
that
go use the code H3
uh links in the description we love
gamer software would they make the kind
with the straw a tumbler
that's interesting the thing about the
Shaker is you really with the ice you
shake it like violently oh so that's how
you prepared the drink yeah exactly so
I'm not sure the straw the straw my
catapult out of it
but we could try if we could maybe try
to engineer something you know
break the whole damn system
introducing straws
but you could have like a flipped straw
we gotta break the system we need straws
anyway love you gamer sup you guys are
the best yeah sup Army sub Nation
speaking of love love love love
hellofresh
fupa Troopers love hellofresh
well tell a fresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip the trips to the grocery store
count on hella fresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why
it's a America's number one meal kit
these meals look so freaking good what
is that chicken parmesan Club
I think it's eggplant yeah
yo I gotta say
I mean look at this
these days I'm more of an eggplant
Parmesan dude eggplant parm is goated it
just it hits so hard I love it when it's
good
yes indeed and sometimes the chicken
parm just is too heavy I don't know what
to say you know it might I feel heavy
such a heavy dish
I'm kind of gooey I might go as far as
to say
chicken parmesan is an overrated dish
I'm gonna put that out there I think
it's an overrated day really people
still have to recovered from your
coaxland there so you may you may want
to slow down here today sorry apologies
yeah but hellofresh
if you want fresh delicious nutritious
wholesome meals sent right to your door
and a beautiful
delivery box with dry ice that stays
nice and cold free all day long no
matter when you get home
that's hellofresh it's cheaper
than going out to eat that's for sure
it's even cheaper than going grocery
store shopping because you don't have to
buy
a [ __ ] bucket load of baby carrots
just because you need like two for the
recipe you know what I mean
uh it's great they send you a card that
shows you how to cook each meal teach
you about the food
you can actually pick up some cooking
skills while you do this too but most of
all you get a delicious home-cooked meal
boom right there so nice
uh you don't have to think about it dude
subscribe to hellofresh and check save
money off your fall to-do list sell a
fresh I already said that thanks
thanks
yeah uh the changing season actually
means changing taste with 30 plus weekly
recipes to choose from hella fresh
something for everyone easily customize
your Meals by swapping proteins or size
and upgrading to Choice proteins or
adding proteins to a veggie meal
love that so go to hellofresh.com after
dark 65 and use the code after dark 65
for 65 off plus free shipping that's a
hell of a deal
thank you to hello fresh
burrito
I'm waiting for them to add Amy's
burrito hellofresh.com after dark 65 use
code after dark 65. 65 off thank you
hello fresh America's number one meal
kit thank you love them man
Apple tea
the Yankees lost can't get gay back on
real fast come on we gotta we gotta get
this they already lost that's quick I
want to see the mood in that room man I
gotta I don't think they've lost you oh
they haven't lost I don't know how the
whole baseball Works wait did they but
they just scored two runs yeah it's four
two oh we got to get them on the phone
it's gonna all right I'm texting him
it's gonna be death in that room bro
it's gonna be like the Deathly Hallows
to make another Harry Potter reference
yeah
oh yeah I was gonna say
um I kind of feel like Tony was like
Hagrid of YouTube in a way we lost
Hagrid and Dumbledore today yeah oh and
that yeah Dumbledore
uh
Dumbledore Vibes with the beard R.I.P to
the goat oh Gabe uh Gabe just left the
house he's not uh he bailed in in front
and sadness and anger yeah
Gabe bailed he's uh not at the in front
of the TV anymore
wow he's like Rage Quit he rage quit his
family
they I cannot express how die-hard
Yankees are I think they all left the
house in separately I can't tell just
from their room oh it's the memorabilia
is everywhere yeah that's insane there
were so many jerseys in the back there
like what's that just
Collectibles I love the Yanks man
Ray says thank you bring me so much joy
many laps I lost three loved ones in the
past year losing our 16 year old pupper
a couple weeks ago geez what's going on
sorry man
love you sorry is it better it's better
to have loved
and lost and never loved at all yes
absolutely what Shakespeare said
definitely guessing that's true he he
was right about a lot of stuff
well if you hear from him let me know
but okay let's move on now let's talk
about something other than the Yankees
or uh
[ __ ] in my eyeballs or whatever
here's some memes to get you started
uh Steve says no to ELA but yes to
Donnie one lucky dog man
that's some good bad behavior
uh golf Donnie here is the clip of him
calling you ugly they're talking and
some jokes giving you an opportunity to
respond here let's take a look the
people who take everything [ __ ] dead
serious to their heart like some just
chill looks like yeah I got jokes
um mad jokes h3h3 no you don't know
you got only one joke Jeffrey dahmers oh
you got one joke
um yeah continue I'm so zany and crazy I
think John Dahmer was cool yeah that was
awesome I believe the word he used is
badass he's a badass I love saying dude
if you're so badass then jerk off with
Donny's heart prove it to me
stay down [ __ ] baby thank you he's
gonna take something out of this and be
like that guy sucks yeah who cares do
you remember how the thing that I've
realized about can you pause either no
do you think he expected us to make two
episodes about this you know we went
even harder than he had thought we would
but a long time I was just gonna ask Eli
did she see this I write a post asking
if they were wearing pants I love it oh
my God it's so funny
yeah I love that
I I yeah I was watching everything and I
watched you guys talk about it all right
I loved it thank you everyone too for
everything that was said all right here
we go oh he doesn't work out so I can't
take his can't take it serious can't
take his opinion seriously damn someone
that doesn't work out and like
talks down I'm working out can't really
take him serious that's when I didn't
take him serious when he related working
out to laser tag that's when I was like
man I can't get over Bradley he's so mad
about the laser tag thing and my point
is it's a hobby Bradley by the way but
you when you were talking about it
wasn't that in relation to covert yeah
so
yeah yeah yeah
like do you guys have a brain I don't
know wait guys
Bradley Martin's assistant wrote us back
this morning saying he's interested in
coming on our show
I'll do it I will I think Bradley's a
sweet guy yeah I do too I think he's got
a beautiful soul a pure heart this whole
[ __ ] thought I'm a huge fan this
whole segment every time Stevie boy says
something Bradley's like hold on hold on
like yeah you can tell
he knows but
um yeah I like him sweetheart man I
would like like to get lost in those
thighs
I need to be there too to make sure you
don't get lost in those ties yeah I know
you gotta hold me back Steve could
literally hold hold me up like by he
could break break me like a wishbone
Daddy
Bradley not Bradley yeah yeah Bradley
not Steve Steve couldn't do that
there's a little guy
this will really get to him
with him on the internet was because
like someone told me that he was talking
[ __ ] about me and like in in retrospect
when I think about all these things I'm
like where along the lines did like I
ever just talk [ __ ] about a random
person oh I wouldn't talk [ __ ] about
something but then again
like a minute later literally barely
even said anything ever yeah no he he
never would except a minute later yeah
yeah yo somebody said when Bradley comes
I Gotta Wear this smallest shorts I can
find oh my God how do these guys keep
their balls in their pants like
legitimately those bit those balls no he
probably had tips there's tape ball tape
there's like double undies no it's like
the Nike Training boxers I think they do
help compression pants yeah I've only
found out about them because of boxing
but they're not perfect I would not be
that confident I'll say maybe he's being
modest he wears them wears them every
day I I ain't wearing them right now
actually but they they're comfortable
under your pants you're wearing well
whatever it is yeah that's fine wait
pancake batters when the balls drip out
on a hot bench
I've never heard of that wait okay who
who among you spends time in the gym
you know not me I've gone four days in a
row I was just wondering if you see
dudes balls ever
uh no not at the boxing gym more at like
a regular gym I feel like there's no
punch balls like the regular gym matter
it's more common to see shorter shorts
dude that's [ __ ] up if I saw a dude's
nut sack I'd be out of there in the
sauna area it happens quite frequently
in the sauna you're that's fine people
are naked in the sauna I'm talking about
lifting weights oh okay balls out
brother
[Laughter]
it's a business for him yeah like he
doesn't have people that love love him
for him being funny I don't think or him
being I'm sure I'm sure
yeah okay I'll just add where I want to
add I just uh specifically here I love
seeing him say it and I love seeing his
girlfriend like disassociate from the
whole yeah yeah
um situation she's in
yeah
total disassociated
I don't know maybe he is funny but like
to me I know that a lot of young males
like me because I was a role model young
multi-millionaire doing crazy things on
YouTube you know
um
what role models talk about themselves
as Road role models does that serious
question like I think that right there
makes you not a role model it's like
impossible to be a legit role model and
be calling yourself a young role model
kav Kev apparently referred to himself
as a role model again proving my point
no shot well I mean
allegedly referring to himself in those
articles that uh
let me just actually I'm gonna play the
fifth on this one I want to play the
fifth driving right I don't get sued all
righty
with
you know you know what I don't really
need to rehashes let me go where he
talks about it yeah at the very end
yell this way we have to end up yeah
right now pretty yeah bro I'm gonna dog
his wanna be a 250 pound podcast host
with with an ugly wife and just talk
[ __ ] about oh dog his wife I'm gonna dog
his wife wait apparently his girlfriend
at the time goes that's [ __ ] up or
something he says that to me yeah
right
nobody's liking what you're putting out
there Stevo well I think they're
probably both like well you probably
shouldn't say that after all you just
said also like they're also keeping his
best interest in Mind by being like
don't you're like actively totally
undermining everything you just said
well and also you just unleash the H3
Trilogy on your ass yo well first it's
like the Lord of the Rings
um joined a list of ugly guys calling me
ugly right
um take a look in the mirror at your
pizza skin I don't know what's going on
there what's your skincare routine
release that let's take a look at it you
know what a skin care routine is
um it starts with vodka I was gonna say
um yeah he does some marination
I don't know what's going on there but
like
I don't know a guy like this calling a
girl ugly is like the biggest software
part it's like this guy yes
you are quite objectively ugly I'm sorry
like it's pretty objective you think so
I never I think he's not that bad
looking because he's in good shape at
least I think so I don't think Steve's
like I don't think he's like totally
ugly
I mean he's not like up on my he's what
would you rate him because he already
called you I'd rate him forgettable like
just another guy I don't know like Auto
one out of 10 nothing interesting I
don't know
yeah now I get it
I mean he's not like he's not obviously
not gorgeous I mean [ __ ]
he's got [ __ ] uh he you know his nose
looks like the surface of the Moon here
he's got craters the size of the Everest
it's a Vibe right now
thank you
missing or hitting
um let's keep going
it's all right bro I'm gonna dog his
wife because she's not pretty that's
fine the haircut's not doing him any
favorites the haircut is not helping bro
I just I don't know it's like the this
is like so unattractive to me I couldn't
even like it's just like
I couldn't care less that he thinks that
I'm ugly yeah I know that
um also maybe I just need to wear some I
don't know a leash or something to turn
you on because obviously
I'm not in the criteria
you say you need to wear what at least
uh
also you need a [ __ ] because he's only
into male dogs we established sure
Donnie bro I'm gonna dog his wife
because she's not pretty that's [ __ ]
and I love how he goes I'm a dogger
because she's committed the biggest
crime yeah she's not pretty yeah I'm
just gonna say it it needs to be said
what but what I have an opinion she's
not pretty nobody asked [ __ ] face no
nobody asked and nobody could care less
like okay and okay if I'm not pretty
like so what
like that's the biggest crime that I can
commit
um I like okay maybe I'm not pretty so I
don't know it's just so stupid you have
you shouldn't exist if you're not pretty
as a woman
it's basically uh why why even be here
well it's clearly what he's saying is
that the most valuable woman can give is
through her appearance because if he's
gonna reference you and that's the only
thing he's going to reference to talk
about your worth I feel like he that
that proves that he sucks he's all but
said that basically maybe when I was
like a teenager this would really like
get to me you know a guy calling him
ugly yeah but um yeah no I I know myself
for it I've I've accomplished stuff not
based on my looks I accomplished stuff
based on other things and I to me that's
what's important in my life and also I
live I have a real man that has really
oh [ __ ] really taught me confidence and
like to see you know my my values I
don't expect all that yeah so and your
bomb not not today this would not like
yeah all I can do is just laugh at you
and think that you're sad he's a boy
he's a little boy that's that's really
what it is yeah he's he's a [ __ ] and
not because you're young young role
model you're 24.
you're 24. you're not that you're young
bro you're not Doogie Howser you're
[ __ ] 24. yeah you're not like a 12
year old not young enough to be walking
around calling yourself young you know
that's just weird that's just like grow
up I agree yeah well said
I do think so I think a real man builds
his his woman up yeah
okay didn't expect all that coming from
you I'd like to hear it though well I've
been waiting since I heard him since I
heard this clip I've been like good man
waiting to talk about good oh thank you
Joe agrees I like that
thank you Joey
straight up like again I would rather
have sex with Jeffrey dahmers than you
go ahead he is really into this idea of
[ __ ] jokes yeah maybe just go dude it
kind of sounds like you really want to
well because he made the same joke in
this episode about something else that's
like yeah his joke is repeating a lot
it's a bit he's going on that I think
actually needs to be analyzed I think we
might need to do a wellness check on
Steve possibly look under the
floorboards
um
there's more than a bit can you change
it I want to do a sound edit here Zach
you can help me with but what I have an
opinion she's not pretty like straight
up like
again I would rather have sex with
Jeffrey dahmers than okay no no what I
want you to do is change it and say I
would rather have sex with Donnie it
sounds basically the same okay and I
think that's what he meant okay I can
definitely do that yeah I'd rather have
sex with Donnie
yeah you have to end the podcast
argue him but Jeffrey dahmers is way
more attractive than your wife okay
that's [ __ ] I mean that's that's a
fine opinion to have if you know I think
that's your preference yeah
God bless you sure I'm sure there's a
lot of people who find him attractive I
mean I disagree I'm not
nothing wrong with that if you find him
attractive or I mean there there is
something wrong though with finding the
dog
that's illegal actually it's kind of
yeah well acting on it's illegal but
yeah acting on it that mental illness of
wanting to have sex with animals is a
condition that needs to be treated and
addressed by a professional yeah
yeah go try it you're saying so much how
much you don't find me attractive and
then that you do find Jeffrey dahmers
with an S attractive
maybe you should go try it it's because
he imagines more than one of them he
just wants he just wants that Dahmer
bukaki
right
right yes right
just making sure
and that's basically it that's it uh
every uh I can't even I don't even know
what days these podcasts will come but
come back every Tuesday raw talk I love
you guys subscribe to the channel
um if you're on that was some Roth
though
he walks away like he ate also yeah he's
like mic drop
yeah I know it's like
it's hilarious yeah so that's that's
Steve will do it and the thing is I
think the reason why we spend so much
time on this is because it's like
incredible how it always happens like
keemstar Andrew Tate ricegum whenever
they come for me they all go
your wife is ugly or boring or like it's
like dude what are you why it's actually
a serious misogyny happening that's
still culturally
most really accepted enough for their
fans and all these guys are very
misogynistic so it all you know lines up
even in that episode I love how he tells
the story about how he did a girl thing
because he went to Russia without money
I don't know why like figure your [ __ ]
out yeah that's kind of [ __ ] dumb bro
it's not a girl thing that's called just
being so we found some girls to buy him
dinner not girls to their fans
[Music]
so that's his opinion of girls it's like
no he thinks very lowly of women clearly
join us and together we'll end women
to movement
solidarity my brothers yeah so shout out
to all the misogynists out there and uh
ela's doing great
you know what I mean
it looks fire he's slaying today and
um Steve if you're watching we can send
you one of these shirts that we're going
to be making here you want to show that
off to steal now we can
because nobody's out of his League Eric
showed off yeah just saying this is all
dedicated to Steve we're gonna make a
special
Teddy fresh
but you can buy it but still
we'll be checking IDs yeah
all right
um
fun times we got
oh this was exciting oh I forgot I
wanted to try to do something so on
Wednesday we made this episode
called nalk attacked Ila here we are
again and we're going to war twitchcon
cringe though yeah and then it ended up
number five on gaming trending so I'm
like let's put some gaming [ __ ] in
the title every time for a gag and see
if we get trending every time like Dan
can you just add like
that's the game that's the game
Eva breaks her silence uh OverWatch 2
release yeah OverWatch 2 release a
disaster no no no that's that's the
that's it'll get us on the gaming
trending so is that true everybody's
talking about the OverWatch [ __ ] right
really that bad let's talk about it I've
actually been enjoying it but but it's
been a very controversial Rocky release
but the point we're doing the talking
about it right now this is it got more
coverage right recovery
so OverWatch 2 released a disaster I
just thinking if we just do end gaming
discussion I don't think that's specific
enough but we got on there because
twitchcon was a trending topic you think
so yeah yeah for sure
all right let's give it a shot [ __ ] it
OverWatch 2 a release a disaster
oh my God
none of our fans would ever click for
that
but it was gonna get on like Brendan
gaming or like the least gaming channel
on YouTube yeah
well as a meme though it's funny like if
we do this every [ __ ] episode until
YouTube bans us from trending yeah yeah
we've been playing you should play with
this Ethan didn't you you used to play
it yeah download that [ __ ] it's free I'm
Tim nothing I mean yeah it's free
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
it's free that's free or I'll spot you
if you need it yeah I can buy it it's
not a big deal it doesn't cost any money
Ethan yeah good thank you Dan
um
all right so did we update the title
sure did dealer breaks or silence
OverWatch 2 release a disaster
so that's the new gag don't be fooled
guys we're definitely not a gaming
channel we're just
and then once that goes don't tell
anybody yeah don't tell YouTube
obviously
bro this title is ridiculous
Ela breaks her silence comma OverWatch 2
release a disaster I feel like this
title is kind of [ __ ] up now it's way
too much gaming
love what do you think
I like it thank you love back me up oh
my God it's a trending topic I don't
know but I mean I don't know to be fair
I don't know how much being on trending
matters I don't think it matters at all
it's just fun but but you were saying
you want to get on there I'm telling you
this will get us on there it's just the
meme absolutely yeah yeah it's just a
funny gag yeah
okay let's give it a shot why not
um
and then once they kick us off gaming
trending we can do beauty or something
like Maybelline new [ __ ] eyelash [ __ ]
let's see what's up I don't know let's
try it you know it's Maybelline whatever
[Laughter]
love that
so that's it that's fun
good times huh
wow
excellent
great very cool you got kind of that was
a little whistle there when you said
that yeah that was interesting oh yo you
guys got to see this video this happened
yesterday
Orange County
no it happened last week but last week
on in Orange County 405.
this is one of the craziest videos I've
seen on the internet
um it's so good
I would think I would call it fake if it
wasn't clearly not fake
I mean this would have to be like a high
budget
uh insane shoot to be fake what the heck
is going on right here
this person's sparking
all doors open
I believe this guy's car is even going
down the 405 freeway but he's making it
happen here on one wheel apparently dude
she's staying in the lane mind your own
business situation been here on the 405
tailgate open there's no tailgate party
going on in sight but this guy is just
letting It All Hang Loose right now this
guy a professional broadcaster like his
commentary is great let's see what this
person's smoking
this is my favorite part
watch it he just casually waves back
[Applause]
really good camera work too all right no
we're good
Miss
looks right now uh
I mean I have somebody help me before
and apparently the break did not do you
know you're driving on three wheels
right now your wheel's completely out
you just crashed into this gentleman oh
my God you're a hazard you're on the
freeway
won't get three wheels you need to get
out of the car I will just just get out
of the car you're on drugs right now
you're on painkillers yes you are
you are on some drugs right now oh my
God put your car
ah
my jaw dropped at that last part when I
watched this video I was like bro you're
on the [ __ ] seat how zoink do you
have to be to not notice that you're on
three wheels and that your trunk is wide
open
oh [ __ ]
probably like staying in Lane yeah she
was right on there she kind of looks put
together
yeah yeah yeah she's like hey nose
everything's good here all under control
you know she got ready for the day she
looks good I agree
her hair is done yeah she's pretty good
look I mean maybe she just hit the
she obviously hit that [ __ ] way too hard
but she seems a pro at getting high too
because I don't think you can get that
high without dying unless you're like
experienced at it right
probably a combination of alcohol and
pills you know who she needs to call I
don't know
well you know who she needs to call oh
yes we do our boy but he's about to get
the dude he's about to get paid let's go
yo can we call him I'd like to get him
how would you defend this yeah yeah
let's go that's what I'm curious
go ahead I don't know who H3 is but I
came here because of the overall it's 2
title
oh welcome Garrett hey Gary no no no
we'll tell you OverWatch 2 uh
it's a huge disaster we'll talk we
talked about it already but we'll touch
on it some more uh yeah no it's it's
rough man it's crazy
with the hang out hang around there's
other good stuff
yeah let's get PP on here to give this
an assessment my wonderful client I can
only see the video now she was driving
down the freeway zonked out of her mind
on on painkillers drunk way over the
legal limit hit three parked cars all
the doors were open she was clawed out
by the jaws of life she took a shot at
the firefighter crashed into a parked
car [ __ ] on the floor puked on an
officer
I'm excited I'm excited and now my
beautiful client
wet and Reckless reduced to wet and
Reckless
oh man
wait some people are saying we're on
trending already
no can't be
that would be the best [ __ ] thing
ever
yo we're gaming now yo they're saying
we're on trending already yo we're on
we're gaming bro
we're Premiere gaming channel
oh my god do you guys really see it I
see lots of people saying that I I don't
like yeah can you go to the game yeah
everybody's checking they're pulling yo
we're Premier gaming
there's no show like this with this many
viewers consistently that's talking
about gaming news somebody says 23 on
gaming specifically
OverWatch is a [ __ ] disaster
what are they doing over a blizzard man
hey squeezing
wow we're a game I wonder if we can
stack it where we're like gaming news
beauty news
can you trend on both maybe guys what
don't mean to be a buzzko I think
they're talking about I guess last
week's or our last step right well we
already knew it was on yeah it was the
whole beginning yeah no they can't be
weird 20 we're 22.
oh from last week from Wednesday yeah
people are saying on Wednesday well
we'll see I think we'll get trolled
people are saying it's at the top for
them
we'll find out we're definitely going to
be on gay on on trending though
and the verdict is
nah the new biggest gaming channel on
YouTube I already need to go to the
bathroom yeah go ahead
oh by the way this one's for you oh this
one's in shekels from ephrat Gila ela's
makeup looks so good also you guys have
to do a makeup tutorial segment with
Olivia we've been actually that's in the
works right there's plans within plans
oh yes feels good to be a gamer
you know what's even crazier different
categories
have different ad rates
I even like like Finance ones bro if we
could tap into that [ __ ]
like if we start talking about like home
mortgages or our interest rates or or no
I think what they really like is like uh
how to make a living online if we did
that [ __ ] hmm you get like twice the CPM
on those videos we should do that so you
can retire better and I'll tell you guys
how to uh I trust them I'll give you my
financial advice I don't know I've got
some stuff to say
it's just alone
um moving on
thank you thank you uh by the way this
clip cracked me up because
the clip is funny
but the part that had me laughing is
is this really how [ __ ] the stream is
bro it's so [ __ ] bad it's crazy and
people stay around this is unwatchable
is that this from the beginning look at
this [ __ ]
why are you guys watching this there's
340 people watching now I don't know why
[Music]
he said Ethan if you're a hostage look
over butt wow that's horrible quality
even worse than I expected eh
I don't know what
well come come watch on YouTube where
the quality is good yeah I mean that is
the point right is to just get people to
come let them know that we're live so I
guess it doesn't it shouldn't be good
otherwise they wouldn't have motivation
to do good right yeah so
but yeah I like it to be [ __ ] I just was
surprised
very [ __ ]
were you able to go live yet baby no no
really
my wife's giving me issues well I got
400 here on Tick Tock so that's pretty
cool what's up Tick Tock
oh everyone yo they're strategizing how
to get me banned people are typing
in the chat report for paid partnership
what yeah that's how they got keep
getting me banned oh my God
undisclosed branded content by the way
the fact that that's even a report
option that's such a snitch ass
report
yeah that's awesome
uh Taylor says thank you eat those look
Ethan's looking good on the weight loss
thanks man
good luck on your own weight loss
Journey there Taylor
what's happening is it really
because I'm still so fat
but I see it everybody sees it
definitely see it yeah very noticeable
if you look back yeah if you look at
episodes from like six months ago it's
huge very noticeable
yeah I was I was I was getting very very
big
but I you know it's like
got a long ways to go I'm out 2 30.
and I think if you look at my body mass
index chart
the healthy weight is like 170.
for my height really
think so
that's like super skinny though
yeah you don't even need to go down to
170. how much do you weigh baby
I weigh 175. there you go and he's got
some muscle he's been working out
[ __ ]
I'm dude it's crazy to think how [ __ ]
fat I am my ass is walking around with
80 extra pounds
right now well at my Prime right now
it's still you know 60. right
now let's look at some fun stuff
enough
here's some fun stuff you guys remember
Big Nick
as a Christian you wanted we had them on
oh I mean it's fun in a weird way
not really fun but it's funny maybe if
you look at it right
it's funny anything's funny if you look
at it right Ela all right
um big Nick called into our show to talk
about David dobrik a while ago
like two years ago now yeah and since
then or maybe he had already begun he's
Found Jesus which as you know
well he's found maggot Jesus is what
he's found I don't think he's found well
he's a born-again he's a born again
and as I always say born against are
just the [ __ ] nuttier than squirrel
turds dude thank you thank you Gare for
the gift I appreciate that
I think it did
yeah there's something about Jesus in
your brain he just scrambles your [ __ ]
up and he's been just putting out the
wildest content you can imagine what's
actually super interesting is he's found
an audience
really yeah
and he's he's popular on Jesus Tick Tock
swear to God send me his Tick Tock link
he's yeah they love his ass on Jesus
Tick Tock here's one he's he just came
out with all this anti-semitic [ __ ] just
kind of
perfect super interesting this is one
that happened he's mourning Christians
do not eat halal meat with peace and
love this is a serious message
stay away from halal meat because it's
actually offered as a sacrifice to
Demons when Muslims slaughter their meat
bro it's just meat
you said demons
wait I'm interested in this well I think
what he's saying is that the Muslims are
the demons
because those are the only people eating
halal meat that I know of right in order
to deem it hold on they have to say
Bismillah Allah
means in the name of it
wait what does that even mean Lena you
you what did he say we say Bismillah
sometimes but it just means like thank
God for the food yeah oh that sounds
really demonic Nick
I've heard that bishmala I like that
[ __ ] when we start prayer that's what
it starts so
so what the [ __ ] is he what the [ __ ] is
he saying then is did you did you can
you extract anything from this um
I don't know so far God is great is what
he said he said thanks for thank God and
God is great he smile peace
hey can you help me with something I'll
also like him like him how do you
pronounce that I can never mind yeah
perfect
say it again Lena gave it a little bit
of extra Arab emphasis but yeah Lena you
do it yeah give me that Arab sting
assalamu alaikum assalamu alaikum it was
hard it's harder with the uh with the
Hebrew version yeah yeah give me the
White Version either
assalam assalam alaikum assalamu alaikum
cam could say cam knows it solidarity my
brother what does that even mean Cam's
gone will peace be upon peace be upon
you oh that's beautiful it's just a
greeting yeah and then you say like
almost like a hello in a way yeah it's a
greeting
that's
it
yeah like hello how are you I'm gonna
take your [ __ ] soul
hello hello yeah you guys are alive
in other words Ninja can you translate
that for us hello
in other words
[Music]
means in the name of Allah and Allahu
Akbar means Allah is greater now many
Muslims will make the debunked claim
that Allah means god in Arabic however
this couldn't be further from the truth
derivative of two words
which means
their God is a pagan Moon deity this
Pagan Moon deity and as you can see in
these ancient hieroglyphs here
that Muslims use in their logos today in
First Corinthians 10 28 it's made very
clear to not eat meat sacrifice to Idols
as a Christian when you eat halal meat
which is meat offered to demonic Pagan
deities they're actually eating cursed
food from demons themselves
about to stay away from all halal meat
that's what I'm saying from literal
demons themselves why don't you go down
that Born Again path your brain gets
absolutely [ __ ] fried Lena have you
ever heard that name I've never even
heard that name he was talking about the
name no there's information I've never
even heard that name yeah I mean that's
like well he goes Muslims try to say
this which has already been debunked
it's like okay Nick and and Allah is the
Arabic word for God so if you're no
that's been debunked
before you pay attention if you're a
Christian Arab you would call Jesus a
love you believe Jesus Is God right it's
yes it's yeah saying any religion has
been debunked is the funniest thing I've
ever well it's not even the religion
it's just a word it's literally a
language I've debunked the language
like it can also have a root in what you
said which it doesn't but I'm saying it
doesn't mean that it doesn't mean God in
their language
oh boy yes so
wow when did all that happen oh my God
it's been that way we'll wait to see the
other one this is this is pretty mild
coming up next wow oh no that was pretty
bad islamophobia it's just saying it's a
false moon deity and their their meat is
cursed demon yeah that's pretty bad it's
pretty bad I'm gonna debunk that I'm
gonna sit here and I'm gonna debunk that
how about Moon night I've eaten oh that
just slaps bro I'm the meat Chef I [ __ ]
with Halal Brothers in New York
those guys make it happen out there in
the streets
um I'm the meat chef so I just love this
um Samantha said Nick looks possessed
unfortunately oh yeah I'm not here to
speak on his physical maybe it's not
physical yeah he his delivery the look
in his eyes yeah
by shooting
can I like
just give him possessed yeah well a lot
of my possessed but it's like what
happened to tolerance it here's like
Islam has been debunked right
well no for real you heard he hates
other religions equally yeah
yeah this part is going to be about yeah
here he goes full opportunity to be
hated here he comes after the Jews this
was a recent one um
actually this kind of blew my mind Megan
McCain
daughter of John McCain everybody knows
who she is I'm assuming
this is her husband
this dude tweeted out Ray J sucks at
rapping almost as much as he sucks at
banging Kim Kardashian
what he did to her was a war crime in
the pathetic sense the earbuds are fine
though
is a war crime in the pathetics
[Music]
this is the husband of Megan McCain
a war crime in the pathetic sense not in
the positive sense like the war crimes
that his father-in-law did but yeah
there's heroic of Warcraft and like
blowing up Villages napalming Villages
and Cambodia and stuff like that you
know that's cool I love that this guy is
like yo I would give Kim Kardashian a
good [ __ ]
work I would give her a good [ __ ] she
deserves boy that's so weird he looks
like a piggy suey
that boy look like he just came down
from the fair oh
come on bring me down at one of them now
deep deep fry turkey down boy
hey is that Benjamin
hey Benji boy
me down one of them deep fried twink is
here now bye
we're gonna be late to the suing
competition to read foreign
[Music]
Dominic is an American writer blogger
editor television commentator he's the
co-founder and publisher for the
Federalist yeah
aren't those guys conservative Family
Values he's talking about how he would
have [ __ ] yeah okay Federalist is like
the like yeah what's uh John McCain's
daughter or she was on The View and she
was like the conservative yeah family
values yeah so like what a crazy tweet
from him yeah and I got totally
sidetracked because I I was looking at
Nick's and then I saw
Candace Owen
said this is Megan McCain's husband no
further comment I don't know what the
[ __ ] her point is but I looked at this
and I was like whoa this guy's wild for
this [ __ ] well because Ray J was at her
premiere Ray J is like on this this same
Kanye wave of like aren't they on the
same team
right and so she's calling this guy out
for being a creep like saying she's
defending she's defending Ray J in this
case but Ben and Ben and Candace seem
like they're on the same team yeah but I
guess not it's more complicated than
that I mean there's sort of like a civil
war happening in conservative world
right now
between the more traditional Republicans
in the Maga the Maga heads that's a
shame you hate to see it
well anyway yeah Megan McCain hates
Trump like she's always like that right
Ray J even a rapper
are you asking me yeah I don't I think
he was he's an R B singer yeah I was
gonna say r b so Ray anyway so anyway
the point is Big Nick wrote Under This
the right wing is just as cringe as the
left with this anti-Semitism cancel
culture ye was on point yay yay did you
just do that again
what you called him Yee so what I call
whatever the [ __ ] I want he's [ __ ] to me
all right that's true I'm not gonna
defend him yeah you know what he's he
from now you know what I actually
embraced that
how much respect do you want me to put
on his name you're totally right you're
totally right [ __ ] it
so this dude is like nah he was on point
with that anti-semi [ __ ] I'm down with
that Defcon 3 on Jewish people
love that for you Nick
here's another one by the way uh PMP is
in our Zoom oh that's exciting
how did you know that
I sent him a link
yes no okay big Nick is in the comments
here what what is this one meant to be I
just see James O'Keefe who's uh oh you
know what
uh yeah it showed up first for me but I
think I may be following him back from
when we were boys let me see
you were boys at one point yeah I mean I
said yeah I said that he was like this
but
he's a bummer James said he forgive he
forgave me is this the Rollie uh Zach
what's this
uh zoom in a little more I can't this is
all I got hold on oh my God it looks
like it yeah yeah
this is James oh queef he is a
right-wing provocateur and Demon
yeah oh here's the actual comment I'll
throw it on screen right now great shot
oh here's Big neck coming out with some
spicy hot 200 likes low they just mad
because he exposing the Jewish World
Order
oh [ __ ] you I'm sure that's the reason
big Nick never came up it's the Jews
the Jews all right do we want to talk to
PMP he's of course I do he's busy man
let's go PNP our uh podcast resident
attorney
for degenerate drug addicts hey PNP
you're at you're out of the uh costume
today hey
how you doing good man how have you been
I've been good man I've been good busy I
saw um
I saw the comments of uh what's that guy
that would jerk off his dog oh yeah yeah
he will do it yeah
yeah terrible man I mean you I think
your response uh was very professional
and appropriate you didn't want to get
into uh talking about his girlfriend of
course not
thank you man I appreciate that listen
I'm trying to find that clip
did it get removed from the dog oh here
it is when you guys highlight it for
some reason anyway so I wanted to show
you
um you're the expert on kind of
getting uh drunken
um
catastrophes walk-in calamities
uh representing them to your the best
year ability so here's one I hope you
haven't seen this video yet I want to
get your legal
if you were to give her legal advice I
kind of just want to pick your brain
about what would you tell her or someone
in a similar situation the best way to
behave okay
all right sounds good so can you see the
video
yeah okay so just tell me to pause if
you have a comment to make okay so here
we go okay sounds good this is uh
this is it here we go
heck is going on right here you full
screen it it's versus sparking all doors
open right here I cannot believe this
guy's car is even going down the 405
freeway but he's making it happen here
maybe have you heard from your mom in
the past couple days
okay
all right rather dangerous situation
Happening Here on the 405
tailgate open there's no tailgate party
going on in sight but this guy is just
letting It All Hang Loose right now
front wheel is definitely out let's see
what this person's smoking
bam
by Hawking
I keep driving within the lane that's
what I have yeah let's go so are you
possibly potentially seeing this like
your honor
she clearly is sober she's in the lane
driving straight down would that be
something you could use or is that
unreasonable
I mean we can't tell if she's listening
to music
music could be super loud right
yeah right that's true that's true
that's a good point so potentially she
couldn't she could not hear the wind or
feel the wind of the trunk open
or her why is the trunk open maybe I
mean is it malfunctioning what's what's
the deal with the trunk oh that's a good
point maybe that model has a history of
malfunctioning trunks
yeah I mean that I wouldn't hang my hat
on that that's kind of like a
you know I don't like car malfunctioning
arguments but
um
you know I mean who knows like maybe it
was just open but let's see let's see
the rest of this video okay okay
interesting I like hearing your thoughts
already
Miss get out of the car
are you on drugs right now no
[Music]
no and apparently the break did not do
you know you're driving on three wheels
right now your wheels completely out you
just crashed into this gentleman right
here you almost you're a hazard you're
on the freeway compromise on the freeway
on that three wheels you need to get out
of the car I will just just get out of
the car man you're on drugs
yeah yeah oh she's yeah she's getting
out of the car it's all good right so
here we go
she did crash into him but we don't know
how bad it was it could have been a
little bump there you see the damage to
the back of his car I can see it you
know I can't tell but based on if we
could
if we can just see small damage if we
could take a guess based on the video it
looks very minor yeah probably just a
bump
okay Miss get out of the car I will just
just get out of the car you're on drugs
right now you're on it's a weird thing
with her tongue yes
a little cottonmouth situation maybe
yeah
you are on some drugs right now
put your car
is that gonna be
those pills I don't know what the one on
the left is the one on the right the
rectangular one looks like Xanax bars
which will you can definitely get a DUI
for that um what's that powdery stuff it
looks like she's I think it might have
been one that she sat on and crushed
here let me try to or if maybe she's
breaking the Xanax yeah here you can see
it better here yeah that that looks like
crash that looks like a crushed pill
actually for sure
okay so I mean that's in plain view also
um all right so here here's the thing
uh the fact that she's driving with
the trunk open and her tire completely
off like it's literally it's a miracle
that she was even able to stay within
one lane yeah
um but that is evidence that she's
totally oblivious and on Xanax or or
whatever it is
um but I mean the analysis doesn't end
right there I mean then she crashes into
this guy so in California at least
there's no crime for uh well
so there's there's DUI okay and then
there's DUI causing injury DUI causing
injury could be charged as a felony or a
misdemeanor
and it's there's no like criteria it's
just how the prosecutor is feeling that
day I've had you know pretty crazy ones
charged as misdemeanor I've had pretty
light ones charges felony who knows
um so it depends on if that guy that she
crashed into tells the police that he's
feeling any pain she can get hit with
the DUI causing injury now the the thing
the good thing for her is she has a
defendable case I've defended cases like
hers successfully and
and the reason why the reason why is
looked like a cop is gonna have to get
there after this video is taken see that
she has like pills and
um you know hopefully he can say he had
probable cause to make an arrest
all right given that he has probable
cause to make an arrest and it's tough
man he's gonna have to like talk to
these Witnesses and hopefully they'll
show them the video and after seeing the
video I think the cop would have
probable cause to make the arrest once
they do that they can do field sobriety
tests
um those aren't very accurate and even
if he gives a breathalyzer that's only
that can only detect alcohol what
they're gonna need to do
um if the cop is trained as a drug
recognition expert they can do the
correct types of Steel sobriety tests if
not they might need to call one in but
in any event they can make the arrest
take her to the station or to a hospital
and uh get her blood you know get her
blood from her and if she refuses the
cops can get something called a McNeely
warrant and always refuse right
but always refuse
not the
not them you're arrested the blood test
with like where they actually
these days I think like the McNeely case
was like a Supreme Court case like in
2016 or so where the justices said it's
uh with a warrant they can now draw your
blood by force before they just for say
okay you know that's it like we're not
gonna we're gonna end there and at trial
we have a jury instruction that'll
presume guilt on on whether or not you
were uh driving at 0.08 or higher or
impaired so they can actually force it
one if you're under arrest they can
force it
if you're under arrest and you refuse
they can force it and after even
sticking the needle in your arm they can
charge you with an enhancement
uh for having refused it and then
they'll still get like the jury
instructions that'll really help the
prosecutor oh damn uh at trial okay so
I'm gonna just do it
yeah but we've got to make this clear
this is important distinction David
before the arrest always refuse it
you want to refuse the optional
breathalyzer the breathalyzer is option
know but the cops will always be like
you know if you blow in it and we see
your under 0.0 weight we'll let you go
Liars come on when are you going to be
under 0.08 under 0.08 is like you had
like one drink that's losing you know
what I mean it's it's kind of ridiculous
yeah it's loser [ __ ] totally you're not
going to be under 0.0 like you wouldn't
pulled over
pull over and they're at .08 or like a
little under but
don't do it usually people are at 0.12
or higher 0.11 even
anyway her case is still good even if
she has Xanax or whatever it is that we
saw in her blood because
there's no per se limit
in California at least
um
like there is with alcohol with alcohol
they've done a bunch of tests and they
decided 0.08 blood alcohol content is
gonna be where we draw the line and so
even if someone doesn't seem impaired
if if they're at 0.08 or higher they're
guilty all right here she seems impaired
but they need you know so they can
charge her with uh
uh being impaired
with drugs but and use like any evidence
against her but it's kind of weak
without a blood result
um but even if they do get the blood
result
it's gonna show like
that she had drugs in her system but no
expert witness is going to be able to
testify that at the time of driving this
number that we see equals impairment
so you're feeling pretty good about this
case if she comes to you she's like yo
this video they got this video you're
feeling like this is not a problem we're
going to be saying my great my great
client here in just a couple weeks
community service yeah yeah not a couple
of weeks they'll fight on this case and
uh I would get my own expert witness
toxicologist and my expert is going to
say the same things I just told you like
hey I mean there's no per se limit here
I mean who knows she took these drugs
the night before and you know it could
have been loud music or she's just on
the freeway
um and then she has a bunch of people
yelling at her to pull over and that can
cause confusing sure yeah right yeah
you almost convinced my ass she's over
two two larger men demanding that she
exits out of her cars that'll be very
distressing yeah larger men screaming at
her yeah I mean that's a scary situation
to be in sure and look I mean she's I
mean she's doing like some great driving
they're staying in the middle of the
road it's like her wheel being like that
performance is Stellar I mean could you
really say that in front of a Judge
David yeah you would say that
yeah I'd say that before 12 jurors I'd
say it just like this three things
what
they have the duty to prove this Beyond
A Reasonable Doubt to a unanimous jury
who knows what her life is like they
won't be able to say she's a drug addict
listen I'm curious about your expert do
you go to the same guy and you guys have
like an arrangement like how does that
work when you get an expert and he shows
up and he's like listen I don't know it
could have been here could have been
then
like who is this guy I do have an expert
I like working with but the thing is
it's not just this one guy there are a
lot of them man I'm telling you like
even even even the guy I use is you know
sometimes the same guy the government
might want to use you know it's just
part of the trade like and how do you
know Los Angeles County
uh and a lot of Courts do this like
probably all of them they have a list of
it's called their panel of expert
Witnesses so I pull up the LA Los
Angeles uh Superior Court uh panel of
expert Witnesses lists and you know you
can just choose an expert off that list
if the client qualifies as Indigent
meaning they they don't make much money
and they're pretty much like on on uh
you know government insurance
they'll qualify to get the county to pay
for this expert and I've done that a lot
and that's it that's the case they write
their report we we announce ready for
jury trial and I offer the prosecutor
hey you know we'll take a white Reckless
here or if you want you can spend the
next week of your life trying to try
this case against me and stress out and
you know you could really lose this
thing
there it is so how do you make sure the
expert's gonna to fall your way you guys
talk about it ahead of time yeah how do
you figure that out
no I already know I mean I've been doing
this I can already see you know I see
the facts but
um yeah we talk ahead of time and they
say something like okay I mean that
sounds like a case that I would I would
reach the same conclusion as you send me
the the discovery do they ever surprise
me though do they ever like kind of [ __ ]
you the experts
not yet not yet because he's like yo
this lady's [ __ ] up
no man I've had to have my own on things
like you wouldn't even I mean like I've
had a guy that was caught twice for
possession of math with intent to sell
and he's got baggies he's got like
scales he's got all the sorts of things
I did a video on this this was during
covid and you know my expert was pretty
good I actually had two experts on that
two different guys because it was two
different instances and and they even
slapped him with an enhancement for
getting caught with a felony while he
was out on bail for the first felony and
you know I got him an awesome deal just
do a little rehab and uh you know he's
done with that but so what did the
experts say to help you out with that
one
uh he was I mean that one was he had
like over an ounce of meth on him one
time on one of them the other one he's
got like probably 10 11 12 grams of meth
on him plus other things
but the thing is he was an addict like
his fingers were all dirty and stuff
right that could be enough for one
addict
and the cops you know their experts are
kind of squares and they really don't
have the real life perspective they just
kind of go through like police training
and they're gonna say oh he's got like
oh like
half a gram anything more than half a
gram is not for personal use and it's
like dude are you serious this guy can
smoke an eighth of meth in like one day
what are you talking about and meth is a
lot cheaper if you buy a lot of it at
once they're for a guy that's living on
you know a lot about math but I I but
that's surprise and who can eyeball how
much an ounce of meth is you need a
scale to make sure the dealer isn't
ripping you off you measure what you
bought for that right David yeah so then
he wants to ration out his meth you
gotta ration that's what I'm saying
David David
um historically addicts aren't the best
at rationing would you say
well if they're on meth you know and
they're you know they can be really uh
organized
that you know yeah I mean have you ever
take an apple uh I have yeah yeah yeah
yeah have you ever tried meth David no
no
just asked because you I don't know you
seem to
yeah I mean just try it once I don't
know I smoke crack once
yeah I mean
uh in high school
you know but didn't really do enough so
you oh you so you did try math
yeah but like yeah
good man I've done a whole bunch yeah I
went to rehab and stuff okay so he knows
oh you went to what did you go to rehab
for
um he said he smoked meth once oh yeah
yeah I mean I was you know it's a long
story yeah it's right here but it's
totally fun yeah if you're not
comfortable I'm gonna press you on it
but I appreciate you just saying you
smoked meth once I mean that's enough to
make me happy I smoke crack once so it's
all good I had the same experience I
didn't try enough and I you know I just
never hit it again the crack pipe but um
my friends made it too right there in
their kitchen well that's I mean yeah
yeah
when they're when it's you know home
baked like some chocolate chip cookies
yeah yeah I mean everything's better
when it's fresh off the uh
like cookies yeah
yeah so all right well it sounds like
this is an easy dub for David of PMP
yeah I don't think we'll go I hope she's
got good representation easy dub I mean
like we'd have to prep for trial and set
the case for trial and maybe even
introduce ourselves to the jurors but
I'm confident that you know a prosecutor
isn't going to want to risk it here and
look a wet Reckless isn't much better
than I mean it's a lot better for the
defendant than a DUI but like I mean the
prosecutor's still getting a conviction
they're still getting you know
everything they want you know for a
prosecutor to push for a DUI when they
can already get a reckless driving a wet
Reckless I mean it's not worth it doing
all that work honestly smart how much is
it how much do you think this lady would
pay
to get through this whole court case
with your firm boom start to finish
like 10 grand what that is my friend you
are that is a good for your services
that's why I can't take a sh I can't
[ __ ] take a piss without a lawyer
charging us 10 grand yeah but the thing
is Ethan these people usually can't
afford lawyers yeah right yeah so it's
off like criminal defense is not easy to
make money and do good work on right
unfortunately a lot of the lawyers that
are really killing it in the criminal
defense game
here at least I mean unless you're
representing like Harvey Weinstein and I
know those lawyers
um those are very few lawyers the
majority of lawyers it's a volume
business and they have to have like
attorneys with less experience that you
know only worked for six months to a
year and then they get a better job and
that's kind of who you're getting if you
go with like a male law firm and that's
what a lot of the popular firms are
um unfortunately unless a client has
like actual money to spend
well I got you know close to 10 grand or
something you're not getting
you know you're likely not getting
someone that's going to really viciously
fight this thing for you
what it what do you do do you do uh
personally six figures seven figures
a year what are we talking here David
oh like in general yeah I mean I'm I'm
look my criminal defense
practice is probably about like like
somewhere between like ten five to ten
percent of my caseload
um I'm doing a lot of elder abuse cases
medical malpractice car accidents man on
a car accident case you can bring home a
lot of money like Med Mal
elder abuse like what's your what's the
biggest uh payout you've had in a single
case
950 000. whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
like is that a lot of my friends are
getting you know it's you know it's a
little upsetting I wish I was but you
know I I get a lot of you know I work
hard and it's up to it's up to God to
send the cases my way well at least you
got that one big boy what was the what
was the how'd you get 9.50 out of that
was that like a you work on like a
contingency or what do you call it yeah
yeah so you guys got a settlement from
what like the insurance company or
something
um well that one was the confidential
settlement but I can tell you it was uh
it was
pretty much like a
sexual assault type thing in the
workplace okay
and how do these people find you someone
like with something that
like they're like wow I've got this case
against my boss this is a huge deal like
how do they find uh David from PNP for
something like that
friend of a friend okay
Word of Mouth well hey you guys are out
there man our people are out there we're
going to bring you some big fish dude
you ever think about becoming yeah yeah
do you ever think about changing over to
her entertainment lawyer
no that's actually my sister's dream
come true she's a lawyer
um and yeah
entertainment lawyer and I know she's
like some class right now on
entertainment law but
you know she works in contracts not
entertainment related it's it's hard to
get into entertainment law
yeah probably hard to find clients out
there at the gate there right yeah I
think the majority of clients are just
need small jobs
like hey can we can we get some kind of
like promo code where like we'll do like
eight code H3 and we get like five
percent commission or something
so
so I wish but uh is that illegal all
states are like this it's illegal to
share fees or take or pay any referral
fee in any way imaginable to any normal
well we're good people so we're still
gonna send them both yeah you can pay
you can love it you can pay you can pay
me under the table uh don't worry about
it all right David thanks man I'm good
I'm happy to know this woman's back on
the road thanks to David from PMP
you got to share the roads with this
lady too all right
I'm gonna take the 405 to go to go home
right now
one of your clients out there is going
to t-bone your ass and send you to an
early grave it's okay I got one of your
great clients
all right David you're the greatest keep
slamming okay keep keep at it we love
you calling in all right thank you guys
thanks David all right David everybody
from PNP attorneys the man wow this is a
great idea McKenzie said help him do a
TV ad
do you like us yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna create like a monster he's
already a monster we don't need this guy
Unleashed on the world anymore
have you been were you crashed under the
influence
did you injure somebody under the
influence of drugs were you just trying
to have a good time call me better call
Dave Hit and Run
drunk other than influence attacking an
officer
hi I'm PMP David here I specialize in
getting guilty as hell
drug addicts off
give me a call I can make it happen
let's go our chat is like obsessed with
him I love that well the story of David
is so good because you know we didn't
expect we didn't know what to expect no
yeah I know and he just turned out to be
such a uh
lovable guy yeah
that is interesting about the rehab I
was about to say that additional lore uh
kind of puts into perspective that you
know he wound up going into a field
where he's uh defending people and he
said previously that that's his
preferred method is to get people into
rehab because where they can actually
get help it's nice he's a good you're a
good man David yeah Ila did you hear the
story he told last time oh I did I was
driving and I was literally like I think
I've made an audible like
myself in the car thinking about wait
what was the story The Gardener oh the
good dog yeah it was so crazy it was a
good story Johnny
by the way thank you to our Saudi
benefactor 50 gift of subs thank you
thank you peace on David
excuse me
I guess we should get on with that we
haven't really gotten to anything
um
[ __ ] it's like every time we talk to him
we peel another layer there's just
always
he's always entertaining he's tried math
too which I appreciate the honesty there
he spoke I think that's what's
interesting that he's like just like so
honest
honest man
honestly there's Joe Rogan clip there's
kids this man is so [ __ ] dumb dude
like I'm just done this man is dumb it's
just laughable at this point
I'm curious what his subreddit is saying
about this because it was posted there I
want there too there's kid well his I
think his the other day I went on to the
Kanye subreddit and like everybody was
like
so over him
it was kind of interesting to see that
because I don't normally check it but
it's been a while
and everything I think the the
anti-semitic thing was just like the
last yeah everybody is just done and and
the white lives matter and the fashion
shows
and Candace
so I kind of wonder if what goes on at
The Joe Rogan subreddit uh well yeah the
Joe The Joe Rogan guys have been kind of
hating on him for a while and so I read
it but here it is uh Joe Rogan on a
recent podcast kids ready for this
my friend his wife is a school teacher
and
she works at a school that had to
install a litter box in the girls room
because there is a girl who's a furry
who identifies as an animal and her
mother
badgered the school until they agreed to
put a litter box in one of the Stalls
yeah so this girl goes into the litter
room or to the the girls room and
urinates or whatever I don't know if she
poops in it that's pretty gross yeah I
mean like if you could teach your cat by
the way here's the thing if you could
teach your cat to use the toilet you
would okay yeah like you don't want a
box of piss in your house it's the word
I've had cats my whole life it's the
worst thing about having cats you got to
clean that box of piss every day yeah
well it's the greatest thing about dogs
they go outside like is you you're a
[ __ ] human cat that's got their
humans trained this oh Tulsi gabbard of
course uh this is like the this is some
myth that's been around forever but it's
so dumb how could you believe that Joe
yeah you even believe that
like just listening to yourself telling
this craziest super dumb story like
maybe just question it for a minute
actually there's even a Wikipedia page
about this hoax because it's been told
for so long
and this [ __ ] actually said
I know a guy's wife
there's kids that's his whole yeah he's
always like that it's always I know a
guy that knows a guy he says
imagine basing your whole perspective on
the world based on someone saying I know
a guy who said yeah
but it's not like oh I heard this it's
like I my friend's wife saw this that's
like a very
incredible
kind of line in there what's that sounds
credible but also so removed it's like
what's that Wikipedia page Dan
oh yeah because when we saw this last
night I just Googled a cat or litter
boxes in classrooms and the top result
is there's a whole Wikipedia page
dedicated to uh debunking this has never
happened by the litter boxes
there's no litter boxes in any school
uh or well not for humans anyway that
would have
gone Tick Tock yeah litter boxes let
that happen I saw Hassan tweet earlier
uh in response to this saying that
apparently this latest round of it came
from
uh buckets in some schools filled with
uh cat litter
um being deployed around the school in
order to uh be used in the case of a
school shooting uh for a lockdown to
like barricade doors and stuff
well because it's really it's heavy like
I mean it's like a sandbag how do you
get first of all that's so [ __ ] up but
how do you get from that to people are
pissing in kitty litter boxes in the
bathroom
because it's not you're just uh a really
sad person that's like just really
reaching trying to find the story that
you want to hear
somebody and the teacher went there
who's like a Maga brain freak saw a
balcony kitty litter and was like dude
you won't believe what I saw there's
kitty litter at the school
but Joe Rogan you are dumb as hell bro
please dude
seek help man
Claim about litter boxes in New York
school is unfounded obviously I mean I
don't need to read this I know that some
things you just gotta trust your gut
there Joey Boy do you trust this Source
though
I trust him well I think you can too
yeah I do I do actually so that was a
shocking one even for even for Joe that
surprised me that dumb meat-headed [ __ ]
Joey you meatheaded [ __ ]
nobody's [ __ ] and kipped boxes damn
it
kavkav messaging someone Apparently one
of our fans
allegedly
this shit's super funny the title is did
cavcv just message me
an anonymous redditor liked your
submission so much they've given you the
love award and included this note
so I can't help but notice that all of
your posts and comments are H3 related I
know for a fact agent 3 Bots their views
and stats on YouTube but had no idea
they were creating fake accounts to post
on Reddit too yikes
anyway continue on your sad existence
so if this person thinks it's a bot why
is it talking to a bot it's
a question oh my god did you just bring
coffee
more caffeine thank you
I needed a hot beverage I'm feeling I
know it's cold here I'm not feeling
fully recovered I've got a little
headache okay a lot of sleep
thank you Lena so much fair enough fair
enough
real quick shout out to uh Bella for a
50 gifted thank you for the gifted two
we have two Saudi benefactors we do yeah
maybe she's the Bella's got to be from
ma Bella uh Bella Italy well
um
maybe Mafia Italian mafia
wow you were [ __ ] quick
[Music]
we won't forget this wonderful gift you
give us today
my Bella Simmons
bottom line is you cannot be trusted she
can be trusted
yeah what do you think this reads like a
cab company
don't you think
kind of do with them like it's just kind
of reasons I can't help but notice it's
like so
such like an entitled kid
yeah I'm getting cavcat vibes from that
they know for a fact that Kevin bought
our stats Cav's the only one that would
say some [ __ ] like that we are paying
good money to lose subscribers on this
channel
oh
Kev cab
if it's a bot why are you messaging it
and why are you saying continue on with
your set existence it just can't get
over there who's the bot you're talking
to a robot who's the [ __ ] bot but you
think you would know about Bots with his
Instagram comments and everything well
that's that's why he sees Bots
everywhere right man top of the tops
the best
what's the cow for
to the Bowl symbol oh Brad the bot bread
right
seeing uh Tick Tock live got banned by
the way in the chat oh okay good okay
good it's become like a
so let's see we got the
bullying and harassment this time oh
boring yeah by the way it gets overruled
every single time so it's pretty
interesting and it doesn't even take
long but
there it is guys
thank you uh to all the tater tots that
tuned in there appreciate that
great gifted gifted
that was fun fun well lasted so shout
out kavcab who's still engaged or well
allegedly yeah we don't know
yeah that is Ryan capitalize
um
little foosie oh this is a fousey I felt
gay at it you know this clip means the
world to me so yeah yeah
it's not a huge are we building up for
like a sound
oh yeah of course we are what did we
call it last time by tier Olympics
tournament tournament
okay that's gonna be epic you know we're
leading up to it every year that's like
the highlight of the Year for me love it
yeah foosi's gonna be a contender man
that one is so good but here it is
actually it's nice to see the video of
it I've been seeing that right but I
want to say this for a long time I
looked at myself in the mirror and I
based myself based on what I read on the
comments I felt worthless I felt ugly I
felt gay I felt that no like I just
based on what they told me
ha ha ha ha ha by the way cut to the
lgbtq I just love it yeah Lily sings is
gay right or bi I don't know she's bi or
gay but I know she's no but this is the
the edit though this is no they do right
right right
yeah yeah she's bi yeah yeah anyway
sorry I love it I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna mess up I thought they
told me gay I felt that no like that's
just based on what they told me
I'm happy and proud to be in the room
with all of you guys right now a lot of
you look so confused but I love all of
you guys and thank you so much
could have taken it further
I felt gay I felt worthless
the quickness with how fast he realizes
that he shouldn't have said that we have
to keep our country gay people
going out of the competition
play that again Zach to keep our country
gate
just based on what they told me yes so
then one more the one that was cracking
me up the
worst edited clip
this [ __ ] is making me laugh so much
[ __ ] all right here we go
this is the way I'm going out of the
competition leaving my friendships
behind black willow and Carrie that's
the hard part
[Laughter]
the way I'm going out of the competition
leaving my friendships behind black
willow and Carrie that's the hard part
what did they do to him
laughs
what the [ __ ] did they do
that this is the way I'm going out of
the competition leaving my friendships
and Carrie that's the hard part
[Laughter]
what do you think happened there fine
I can make a guess I think that this is
the way I'm going out of the competition
leaving so I think what they did is they
foreign
well here's what happened
they cut the audio and they put this
clip over to hide the cut yeah
but then they somehow stretched the
audio and never fixed it oh and ships
wow
behind
behind black willow and Carrie that's
the hard part oh [ __ ] bro
[Music]
[ __ ] God damn [ __ ]
it's too funny
what show is this from yeah what even is
this that's drag race yeah
this is the way I'm going out with the
high Budget Truck competition leaving my
friendships behind me
behind it's so good
oh [ __ ] my friendship's behind
[Laughter]
what's the weirdest there's a cut
afterwards so I feel like somebody
granlit that ships behind black willow
oh [ __ ]
there it is folks
it's a good one huh
there's so much left to do my goodness
[Music]
what's the best well we have the we got
to do the sculpting one probably I would
like to do that or we can save that for
another up if no I'm gonna give it it's
due time
well we've only been going for two hours
eight minutes so all right let's we
definitely have time to do it let's just
do that yeah okay so without further ado
this all started by the way when we saw
[Music]
the most busted ass
wax statue of Michael B Jordan look at
this [ __ ] wait what his ass his
head is stretched out like that audio we
just heard no that's a wax figure
oh my God that looks that's someone else
man
yeah pretty good right
and it's like they were only given one
photo and that photo was like weirdly
stretched and they just worked off of
that so this inspired a whole Saga here
at the office Ian Zach and Sam went to
the Hollywood Wax Museum for research on
how to capture the celebrity Essence for
making me the ultimate celebrities wax
figure which we'll be donating
to the Hollywood Wax Museum after this
they'll be happy the entire crew made
their own version I have to warn you
guys the audio for this segment is [ __ ]
just in the first part yeah just in the
first part but uh but I liked it I
thought it was a absolute shame to cut
it
it was pitching the whole time so I can
peeking it was like tearing at the top
so I think what what we did is we
lowered it a bit so it doesn't offend
your ears when we added subtitles yes uh
it's the best we can do so apologies in
advance Chad is also asking for put
Lovato okay well that one's Evergreen if
we I'll try I'll do it next if we have
time okay
um so without further ado
roll it
famous Hollywood Wax Museum it's not
Madame Tussauds because we did not have
the budget for that I've come here with
Zach I've come here with Sam to see what
it takes to make a truly authentic wax
figure looking for some inspiration on
the soon to be unveiled Ethan Klein wax
figure I'm excited I'm looking forward
to this hoping you know I could have my
own wax figure one day you kind of look
like one already
like you kind of have that Sheen
you know if you keep talking to me like
this I'm gonna walk he's always
threatening to walk I'm gonna walk Zach
gave me this shirt I just want to make
that clear I did not buy this shirt you
like the shirt it's it's a shirt and it
and when the laundry day comes it's a
shirt anyways let's get to the wax
figures
I'm curious why this is on the Pirates
of the Caribbean ship dropping at grumpy
looking at his legal bill wait hold on
Sam where did you get that I got it from
the pop station you know that's probably
covered in like lice Omicron and stuff
right you're just itching what was that
about ever since I put the Hat on it I
can't lie okay we gotta move to another
station are the features on the Elvis
here his nose is bleeding a little bit
that's from the MK Ultra program failing
when they cloned this version of Elvis
this is Otis or something I don't know
who this guy is why does he have Emma
Stone walked in his dungeon behind her
that's Amy Adams no that's Emma Stone
look at his hands they look like they're
covered in glue I think that's going to
be an important factor when we go to do
this can you look in the mouth he's
really got a mouthful of bubble gum just
boiling in there it's really fantastic
sorry to keep harping on looking in the
mouths I think there's like a spider
growing in there she needs Jimmy Lee
ASAP we're gonna play a game called
Who's That Celebrity with Sam Sam has
never seen a movie and Sam doesn't know
a single celebrity tell me who that is
Michael Rapaport okay I don't I've never
seen this man in my life I have no I
don't know who this is Red Hulk Indiana
Jones Wolverine Jason I think his name
is Freddie Amy Adams Ryan Reynolds Jimmy
Kimmel's co-host Al Pacino I think her
name is Jennifer oh my God I don't know
I don't know Steve Carell I don't know
he gives me Bradley Cooper but we
already saw Bradley Cooper what's the
guy's name from The Hangover the main
guy from Hangover this is Jason Bourne
this is Whitney Cummings I'm so
disappointed right now please look at
how they did my queen I've seen her in
person I've been her show seven times
Lady Gaga is five foot two I'm five five
they did Prince dirty man I'm sorry this
looks like [ __ ] I don't know who this
woman is that's Adriana venti they
really nailed the fighter stance
can somebody send this to a b if he uses
this dance in his next uh boxing matches
that this might be more effective
sexiest man alive Ryan Gosling this guy
guys [ __ ] dude look at him he [ __ ] Sam
does this guy [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
yes Channing Tatum they made him kind of
like this cute Kawaii character which I
think we could use that for defense I
think that could be good when he fell
off the Titanic his body got a little
waterlogged like an old sponge family
family
would you like to comment on Taylor
Swift I know you have some hot takes
about her I think she's great
[Music]
I don't want
well then you gotta put the hat on
now say Shake It Off Shake It Off
when it comes to wax figures make the
fingers look as crunchy covered in slime
and dirt and grease like they just got
slow cooked and the meat's just dripping
off of their Skellington now that we've
learned how to make a wax figure Not A
Wack figure we're no longer anti-waxers
so let's go to the H3 compound and put
our skills to the test mannequin no
longer wait see you there
transition we are here at the H3 School
of Art coming together to make wax
figure of the one and only Ethan Klein
first things first we have no wax we
have air dry modeling clay
I printed out some reference photos of
Ethan this is gonna be mine right there
avian cam there you go uh Olivia there's
yours we're starting to lose a little
income now what the [ __ ] is this
if Miss Temple can just kind of give us
some lead here we're going to jump right
into it
so when do we start I have to go over
everything we have on the table I'm
pooping my temple I want to start now I
need to poop in my pants everyone has a
bag in between you yes
never mind never mind random tools that
you can use
does this go up my nose Miss Temple I
don't think it's fair Cam's an artist
this is unfair competition I still get
three he's a very talented
Miss Temple this Temple yes
I'm excited to do this
it's all about the technique guys
got like the uh the top layer of the
skull here on and I'm working on the
most important part which is his double
chin right now I'm I'm on the double
chin as is Dan copying my work no here's
the thing is
copying my work no I'm gonna move it has
that nice like Moon crater thank you yes
the acne scars you give me a [ __ ] up
picture Ethan is this what you're trying
to recreate my best yeah
it makes me look more artsy than I
actually am tell me how you feeling
about it
not great little Michael Jackson knows
right here for him I'm actually just
gonna make Michael Jackson and see if he
notices earlier there was there was a
bit of an issue I may have
unintentionally made an extremely
anti-semitic nose for Ethan very large
and very hooked we don't have to go full
Turner Diaries here it looks like dream
like not the guy like it looks like his
little face kind of I'm like done so I
don't know what you're all doing yeah
it's kind of horrific looking what are
you trying to say about our boss man so
you've had a cigarette in your mouth for
about 45 minutes yeah it's stuck to the
top lift it's drooping a little bit yeah
I'm impressed with my work so far if I'm
being nice mine looks literally exactly
like jigsaw right now is this is
cheekbone or his eye this is his
cheekbone looks like it's melted
I'm not even like close to being [ __ ]
done I'm not saying that it looks done
I'm saying right now what the [ __ ] is
that the nose is so [ __ ] up you're
talking about my nose yeah are you
[ __ ] kidding me what is this is
Sac this is literally a scrotum right
here Nina just got here we have been at
it for three hours there's a little bit
of catching up to do I'm looking at all
these other heads and I'm a little bit
nervous Sam's had a cigarette in his
mouth for three hours it's very
intimidating
[Music]
three hours later it is looking like the
Louvre in here our artists are tired
but they've created beautiful art today
working so hard anyways
back to you in the studio let's hear
from our judges well thank you everybody
you know
it's it's clear that you guys put your
heart and soul each and every one of you
I want to thank you for your of course
contributions did it all for you to the
art you know
and I see you guys honored me with the
nicest picture of course you could find
of me
yeah I mean from a wedding
right a beautiful yeah you're looking I
was actually at that wedding was
probably my Peak fat right don't you
think probably yeah that was before you
started yeah yeah that was like right
before the diet well right before covid
we got covered human yeah yeah but hey
let's forget about all that so up first
we're looking at uh who's who's are we
looking at first oh we don't know who's
yeah so what we'll do is you will try
and uh guess we've got a chart and you
can pick who's this who's let's see
right here
and then uh we will pick our like top
three and we'll have the audience vote
on the best okay all right so uh can you
okay good thank you yeah just give me a
whole 360 there
you know it's not bad
there's some artistry
that went in here into this have you
guys seen hmm have you seen the ELA have
you seen this theory about how all these
like um
ancient Roman statues were actually
colored they look like idiots I don't
think that's a theory I think that's
just I didn't that's a bad dude they are
so ugly you gotta pull it up yeah it
ruined these old sculptures for me
apparently the Greek used to actually
use marble and they were these beautiful
marble sculptures but but um the Romans
which is a lot of the famous sculpting
that we find
[Music]
um is just hideous when reimagined here
but it reminds me of that not in the
Hideous way but just the way it's
colored uh it is hideous but that's not
the felter's fault I feel like I
recognized the nose from uh dance
sculpture though is that it's not super
anti-semitic the nose
I mean gosh who could say I'm feeling a
b with this one for some reason I don't
know they're APR then I don't think
that's a Dan creation I think that's an
AB creation
yeah you can you can you can do AV on
that one
okay did you find one of those
sculptures then
uh yeah I did actually pull that up
you're talking about stuff look at that
[ __ ]
oh wild that looks like
so childish compared to totally without
the color because you see these exactly
it's just wow Ronald McDonald shocking
to see yeah
yeah look at this one is the most
shocking I'm glad Dan was able to find a
really high horse with the collar
yeah the one on the left is like amazing
here here's a uh yeah here's a much
crisper version of that same oh yeah the
met recently did a a show about what
they looked like originally wow that's
so much worse so bad
I'm kind of shocked I've never seen this
yeah so like the one on the left is like
gorgeous and then one on the right is
like what you see at the mall totally
crazy
because the paint like covers the
Artistry of how incredible it is but
okay up next let's see okay this one's
uh we have wow okay the hair wow
it looks more like you thank you this
one is [ __ ] busted as [ __ ] dude
holy God
it does look like me though that's
what's so funny the other one had
nothing to do
it was a different person let me see
this one again my goodness it does look
like me that's what's impressive and
also scary
yeah give me a 360 if you could please I
have no idea who made that
uh Colin now we are running low on
Ethan's bus
this one can be yours
I saw someone working that dub who would
work that double chin uh Sam was talking
about the chain or not Sam Olivia was
talking about the chin I'm thinking then
I'm thinking
the hair element how many of the other
ones have hair
uh most of them actually have uh you're
talking about like the cotton hair or
whatever yeah yeah I think most have
that
[Music]
I'm gonna say this one's Sam Maybe
it's looking good I think cams is going
to be better no offense to him
it's like really good though and very
disturbing so thank you for that
yeah I don't know if people are
interested but the winner we're going to
be selling online at h3shop.com like
Jordan Peterson bus oh wow that we
bought really it's 500.
and uh you can have me your Idol
[Music]
on your shelf oh
[Music]
I gotta say yeah I hate doing sculpture
so don't don't expect too much out of me
it's really difficult all right I hate
it I just I can't stand it all right let
me see I kind of hated it too when I was
in art school
I feel like that's Cam
why would he say that in his own it's
like crazy to do that whoa though
oh what the [ __ ] dude
and that's definitely what's wrong with
you guys why would you do that it's
really hard Kim why would you say that
as yours came up I don't think he knew
what was coming
okay yeah that's definitely he's in the
clear I mean the Artistry the detail
the yeah the execution is very
impressive
I [ __ ] you hate it though yeah like
but you can tell that there's a little
more
technical understanding the painting is
done very very well yeah like the way
the chin is like more realistic well
thank you very realisticated sideways
turn it sideways like to a person here's
this realistic chin Gila was talking
about
compared to the other ones
well I think it's really good and just
really the eyebrows are kind of I've
never felt worse about myself so thank
you guys
that's definitely Cameron's yeah the
Cameron yeah okay
really good actually
got it
[Music]
up next we have
wow this is [ __ ] Interesting Man
I would have done that whoa wait a
second
wait a second
maybe Ian this one has got there's some
real artistic uh it's like funny
right there's a definitely distinct
humor that we're not a distinct Style
look let me this is very good what's
going on on the ear though
something dripping oh
and it looks like this one suffered a
crack
um they're all kind of cracking
[Music]
but no it looks good I mean this thing
can dangling a little bit there but
overlooked that
and what's with the big old white goo on
the front what's that about I
and then it's like to show sometimes you
have a little white here maybe yeah a
little white streak yeah
I do
okay
and let me see the profile once more let
me see the chin
[Music]
I think this could be Sam I don't think
yeah this one could be Sam it could
definitely be Sam
it could be I don't know how
I don't know how good of an artist Ian
is I've just never seen his art
but I think that whoever made this has
some skills as an artist you had said
this was Sam yeah so I'm gonna I think
this new one is Sam's
and I think the old one
is going to be
Zach or Ian
yeah
what do you think Ian if I know but for
now yeah we'll put that as Ian
I've always heard that about myself
and interestingly interestingly after
seeing these I also feel like hiding in
a hole
it don't look anything like you
look at this one what these are
oh quite good yeah
wow that's a that's a strong chin man
love to see it
this one is like the strongest one so
far wow
give me a whole 360 could you please
you punch up the 3D 3D 4D these are
really good guys I have to say like
there hasn't really been a bad one yet
hmm oh my goodness see I don't know
who's this one then I don't know Lena
artistic capabilities I don't I think I
don't think Dan is very good artist I
just I think I've seen him drawn it's
not that good I don't think Zach is a
very good artist I like Elena is
probably artistic yeah or Olivia might
also be I don't know I mean she probably
is I'm in fact if you do makeup so good
you gotta have Right Touch
that's so true ELO that's so true
so true let's give that one to Olivia
[Music]
wait
it's not Olivia why'd she react like
that
it's not Olivia
oh
she reacted to made me suspicious
because I said let's give this to Olivia
and she said oh thank you you think that
means it's not hers I do
um
people are saying that one Sam I'm so
confused
okay let's leave it on Olivia for now
keep uh
keep looking
so up next
what in God's [ __ ] green ass
you've got to be [ __ ] me with that
besides being horrifying yeah thank you
thank you Ian I definitely see the
resemblance
it's actually very good again really
really quite good oh my God I actually
think the wrinkles like and again it's
not about you but just as like
like trying to get a person
nailed down the wrinkles really add here
bro it's a nice touch I was expecting
some like kindergarten looking [ __ ] yeah
these you guys are really all very good
I can't wait to ex put these heads on
display somewhere in the office
we're just thinking of getting a a case
for all of them we have to put it behind
glass to preserve them
oh my good that's going to be one of the
great displays of our time
I'm just so stumped at this point
we do still have Lena that we haven't
said and Zach I'm expecting Zach's to be
bad and no offense act that's just what
it is
I think that ab1 might be Zach's because
that's probably the worst one so far
just
in terms of
execution with peace and love
of course so wait whoa another good one
well hold on we did we didn't pick yet
okay let's put Lena on that one that
crazy ass one I think we got cams all
wrong Maybe
[Music]
[ __ ]
yeah okay go ahead uh show us the new
one
what yeah
what the [ __ ] okay now I wonder if this
one is Cam
dude this is Wally it does yeah it looks
like him
this one actually has really uh almost
masterful yeah Clay Strokes they work
the clay like a real master the cheeks
look good that look at that huh
just like me
this one has gotta be
gotta be careful it's Gotta Be cam yeah
it's so good
um it's so wild it's very distinct I'll
say that this person took a more refined
approach that the hair lots of detailing
thing yeah really good right on right on
so if we could go put Cameron there yeah
put Zach where AB is
put Zach where a b is right sorry Zach
and then
a B I don't know a b we could be 100
Wrong by the way I think the only one
I'm actually think I'm right about is
Zach
[Music]
um
can we move
um can we move Sam's face from being
over it yeah okay
thank you
let's see
what okay wait we need we have to hold
on let's just what
dude what
I'm kind of oh my God what I'm
speechless looking at this what happened
there
wait
I'm I'm
speechless that's a good soy face though
[Laughter]
it's almost racist doing with it
I I I'm flabbergasted I truly and
this might be the first time I've been
flabbergasted
[Laughter]
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
oh my God it's not bad it's incredible
it speaks to my soul it's stirring
something in me
you know what I mean
foreign
this thing is speaking to my soul in
ways the eyebrows are very expressive
you know why do I look like so
despairingly
so much despair I know who it is it's AV
said he was gonna do Michael Jackson
nose oh is that supposed to be Michael
Jackson it knows yeah give me the
profile but why is he so hairy Michael
Jackson ain't that [ __ ] Harry no then
no
yeah I think he might be right that's a
b but this the uh whoever whoever's the
artist is deeply Disturbed I could tell
is just some underlying issues there
it reminds me of like schizophrenics
last
or or Alzheimer's patients last Sculptor
before death
give me the full 360 please
ah this thing belongs in a gallery I
mean it's truly
it's not bad I have to emphasize that
this is not
it actually is is quite good in the way
it just says so much it's expressive
[ __ ] me
[Laughter]
yeah I'm gonna I guess I'll give it to a
B I mean I'm just utterly
this is
I was not prepared for this looking at
all these busts right now I'm feeling
something interesting and I don't know
what
wait is there a person we didn't
all right that's everything that's
everyone
God
I'm sorry these are gonna haunt my
dreams I'm not kidding like I will
see these before I die I think the last
one more so and I will no care
it's on the last one I'm looking at like
my demons
I'm truly tripping out right now looking
at these
if I was on Asher right now I might
never come back from this trip
golly should we check the chat to see
what they think let's see swap Dan and
Ian I think just
oh [ __ ] out
[Applause]
um yeah I do wonder about Dan and Ian's
because I feel like we weren't really
confident in those decisions I gotta say
first of all
[Music]
the level of execution here is is
tremendous amazing yeah tremendous
okay now look at this it's like the
founding fathers
laughs
this is like these are all my Bizarro
wait hold on can you open up that
handheld mic all right go ahead this is
like a Bizarro Ethan and all the
alternate universes this is like smart
Ethan
sadist Ethan
uh
Samurai Ethan
okay
so first of all
okay this is Godly
which one we're saying was Zach's this
one
[Music]
yeah I think we said that one Zach
or was it the one yeah it was that one
this one's really throwing me off I
don't know who's this one is right
[Music]
[ __ ] me dude it's so hard to tell I
think this one's Cameron's though I'm
gonna say that we got that one I think
looking at it I think I'm gonna call
okay I know this one is Sam's this one
is Ian's this one's Ian's I'm calling it
this one right here yeah
okay
so we gotta update
uh so you're sorry I was uh running over
there to address the camera but um this
one's Ian's
so he's moving the second from the left
top left second to en this one yeah okay
so that's Ian can they see me
yeah
and which one you said is Sam okay
this one's Sam's
so I think that's the bottom left
okay so that means we're moving Olivia
the rest of these are good could be up
for [ __ ]
and then we know a B's
this one I'm gonna say Lena
thank you
this one
okay
gee will occurs man
someone's really [ __ ] up who did this
one
which one are you so now you have Olivia
and Dan
who's more [ __ ] who's the most [ __ ] up
person in the office
[Music]
well don't forget
I have Joker brain
that's true well I did give Lena a
pretty [ __ ] up one
that one's pretty wild oh God this one's
Olivia's look at the shading on the
cheeks
that's the craziest knife detective work
bro I don't know I don't know you guys I
think that would be a good clue
yeah the chi
[ __ ] me
golly
where is that one I don't know I can't
call you guys you guys got to reveal to
me I'm stumped we can do the reveal
uh well no I'll tell him after okay I'll
tell him yeah you're right you're right
all right so take one last look at this
because you didn't you didn't which one
was you were you saying this one was
Olivia because of the shading I think
it's kind of hard to tell Olivia's top
right
understand was oh this one I think maybe
move Lina back to where she was then
which is up yeah and then me on this one
yeah yeah that's fine with that all
right all right so
do you need to do a vote first
no I think no we were going to vote what
everybody's favorite was at the end okay
so out of these from what I can see
you have
exactly one correct was it Zach
this is indeed cams yeah masterful
Strokes there everyone else we got wrong
huh yep so let me uh wow them all here
and one by one I will assign them to
their correct one I'm offended that you
thought that was me you said Michael
Jackson
and by the way I looked at AB and he was
nodding so I was like um
so I'm shaking my head this one maybe
right here okay oh
I thought this one right here the one
that's kind of wild this is the one with
the swirl on the top of the hair
[Music]
that one is so good Lena well you you
took you took like Cameron a unique
approach yeah uh that's like on the hair
and some details there
that's like a real artist like you have
a point of view oh my gosh thank you she
has that's right that's right all right
wow this one right here yeah
that's Olivia okay so Olivia you have
demons I don't know what to tell you
that one greatly in this office too
she's a Defender uh this one right here
that's Sam oh okay okay that is that oh
that's the good shading one right yeah
yeah and it's the one that has the real
wild like droopy uh oh and those are
certainly human eyes in Sam's right
every time I see it I get so free it's
the the eyelids this one
is the one that I think surprised me the
most just the the the Artistry
um
this one's Ian's okay I think he did a
great job yeah super nice when they're
in and yeah this one I'm shocked you got
wrong this one's [ __ ] hot are you
kidding me oh my God and this one is me
so that's that's okay no no
[Music]
let me just break this down
[Music]
the crazy one is back no I'm taking it
I'm taking it in
sucked if there's a raw Shack test you
know Zach but I don't know what this
does about you I'm sticking to my day
job that's what it is no no it's not at
the Artistry I'm critiquing the Artistry
is good
and Dan's okay so you're okay Dan wow
you're kind of you won my least favorite
yeah oh well thank you thank you
just in terms of of I like it I think in
terms of
I want to say yeah I know I I am no
sculptor I don't think I've sculpted
since I was about seven years old
but
I feel like I did a really good job on
your beard I feel like my beard looks
semi-realistic compared to most of these
you're you think it's the hair that kind
of feels was like yeah yeah I don't feel
like doing the cotton thing
yeah I was in here but I was happy it's
not my least favorite I love them all
day I love all my children equally I'm
impressed by all of them and yours Dan
as well I am really impressed so the
clue that AB was mentioning I sent we
had like a grid of all of them and I
sent it to my girlfriend last night and
she was like
I know this one this one and this one
because they all look like a cross
between Ethan and yourselves and it
dawned on us that that's totally true
look there's a b in this what I don't
see that white guys messed up hair I
guess okay messed up back with the dark
beard and everything and he's got the
nice juicy lips what
obviously saw something because she
guessed them right
for mine at one point I was gonna put
Ela behind you like the sample photo but
it was just too cursed but yeah I can
imagine how
but this one actually is the most
realistic Camerons
um
it looked more like you before I painted
it but it really did it became into
Wally
[ __ ] me you guys are talented yeah
so um
do you want to pull the audience see
what their favorite was yeah how can you
even vote on these I mean they're also
well I think maybe just you guys pick
maybe your top three and then we'll have
a poll of those rather than pull all of
them my top three would be
Zacks
thank you
Lena's is one of my favorites okay
Lena's Lena
and Ian I think
and I would say
Sam's is really [ __ ] up too and
Olivia's is like super [ __ ] up I was
living for the delusion I was like we
were sitting there for a while so after
like an hour I thought I was an artistic
she was like this is so good I was like
you guys it is believe this no it is
it's freaky like in a good way like it's
just it's crazy
it has like a real stare like it's
bearing and Sam's is super [ __ ] up too
but if I have to choose which I I love
to do
[Music]
I think I agree
[Music]
I also need to remember what it looks
like true I'm sorry yeah it doesn't do
it justice
but I I'm gonna agree with you I think I
think Ian's
Jax Zach stirred something in me that
yeah nobody's good
so Zach Lena and Ian those three I'm I'm
honestly going off a motion because I
feel like that's the only way I can
judge these I feel like Lena's like I
can see that this guy is a comedian
he is serving comedian you know I
thought it was Ian's just because it had
it such a comedic yeah uh perspective
Lena yeah there was such a interesting
editorial right thing there I thought
for sure had to be in but Ian's actually
does have a
[ __ ]
so if I go just on a motion just like
wow Ian Zach
and I gotta say sam and Olivia those are
the ones that [ __ ] me up the most
where I like reevaluated and questioned
my my identity as as a person it's not
really a it's not really a judgment of
Artistry what it did to you it's what I
felt is emotionally what I felt when I
saw it so Zach Sam Ian and Elizabeth but
ultimately
[Music]
I think it's honestly just between Ian
and Zach
this is like
petition because Zach is so abstract
that's why I'm that's what I'm saying is
that that's why I'm Going On Emotion
only
I think
you need another Yeah well yeah it's
before the poll for sure because it's
the 3D
view that you gotta see no obviously
Cameron's is good but it didn't stir
within me uh
The Winds of Oblivion uh behind my eyes
what do you got Cameron's is good
obviously this is about emotion I
thought it was about capturing likeness
for a wax museum I I would have given
you well yours well yours doesn't look
anything like me uh yeah I guess yeah
it's very good but
the one that looks the most like me if
I'm just going on that
show me the show me the
the full spread
the one that looks the most like me I
think was the one that um
was it a B made
the one in the top left
yeah that one looks the most like me I
think
[Music]
I don't know do you agree Ela
[Applause]
because the
oh
good
[Music]
really
oh Bradley just tweeted me
Bradley said
H3 come on my podcast no you come on my
podcast I want the views
yeah I already said you come on my
podcast Bradley no you they just say no
you I mean yeah no you you come on my
podcast Bradley you come here and then
I'll do your podcast you can do know you
heart so that he knows what's nice all
right yeah
and
can you I'm gonna blow that [ __ ] I hate
doing other people's podcasts boy it
always turns into some weird [ __ ]
but I'll do I'll do his podcast but you
got to come here first Bradley
bring those badass bring those tree
trunks in here boy
oh here's another the top comment's
actually nice if you listen to the show
you would know he actually really likes
you and is scared of your thighs
watch the whole thing not just the clip
nice
that's true uh Brad
okay now so what are we doing we're
voting on all of them now we're changing
the rules
okay so here you guys can vote
it's one through eight
[Music]
on I think you should add then the poll
isn't gonna match that
in order just well we need to add the
name of the number maybe we're gonna be
having a bad poll here guys okay can you
pull that back I don't where did you get
that image I sent it in Discord for you
okay
yes so one
this is Zach's cams Olivia's and Lena's
Sam's AVS and dance I knew how did I
remember that yeah
impressed the [ __ ] I'm telling you dude
sculptures are [ __ ] with my head dude
I never remember [ __ ]
because it says something about them I
see them in it you understand I'm
looking at a mirror of myself and them
and it's not good
I think we should do
we'll do this one and then let's take a
second Poll for which one looks the most
like me I said we'll do a second oh dude
what's your problem I said let's do this
one and then we'll do a second one I
think you you said the dance was your
least favorite
I think it's that's kind of again oh
that yeah that's it come on Dan it's
just just uh it's just you just keep
switching up I've set up three poles
that's what you doing okay
and we'll do another pull who's this a b
this is best in show this is Best in
Show
Bradley I'm gonna I'll I'm gonna follow
you so that we can
you do that'd be fun ELO did you want to
see the uh
the little popsicle looking thing oh
baby it was based off the sample photo I
just wanted like that would have been
funny though
all right Bradley I'm following you
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's talk shop brother
let's lift some weights brother
how do I get thighs like those
okay got it set up I'm going to start
spamming it in the live chat but you
know if we could become friendly with
Bradley who's a great guy and I like him
that opens the road to a lot of other
people to squashing some serious beefs
yeah
I have a newfound respect for Kyle the
Nell Kyle as well yeah yeah
Steve I can let bygones be guy but
bygones with Steve
uh if he I think he might I think I
might be in too deep with him as far as
he's concerned Donnie
Tony
but okay let's let's focus on the task
at hand so this is best in show this is
emotional stirring this is
we'll do another poll after this for
which one looks the most like me so this
poll is like for the fan favorite isn't
it this is just yeah favorite most
powerful most impactful Miss
Congeniality
um
[ __ ] me they're so good I'm I'm about
yeah I'm a vote for mine
show results did you vote yellow
no
so the votes are coming in
Lots across the board is interesting to
see
lots of opinions out there
Dan's in last place so
thank you pointing that out he only has
30 votes actually it's almost like
someone has sway over the vote oh stop
it that one's obviously the worst
[Music]
I mean mine would look [ __ ] I'm not a
good artist it's not a criticism of Dan
Dan's a great guy
I'm honestly shocked you like mine more
dude yours is [ __ ] I voted for yours did
you really yeah oh my God
actually and you're in second place
right now Zach wow thank you that that's
amazing
it doesn't look anything like me
but it's [ __ ] me up
will you put it in your house like no
way hell no absolutely not
oh
I think we have enough Theodore will ask
what is this
well the winner actually is
[Music]
um
Ian
thank you I knew he was gonna work Ian
one or three which would be number four
right yeah let me bring this thing let's
take a look
at the I was very impressed watching Ian
make his
oh that's so he did it with tender love
yes yeah they're all very extremely yeah
we had to do some uh some some glue
triage earlier so this is just clay that
dried naturally so it's pretty brittle
yeah it's a little fragile there it is
guys
that's Ian congratulations Ian thank you
and here's one for the uh Guinness or
The Oddities store or whatever it does
look like me actually there is
there is something going on there let me
get a zoom
a little bit a little it's hard it's
very hard yeah
I was like I was telling Sam I'm like we
should do this just for fun yeah we were
all in the zone we looked at the clock
had been three hours we just had so much
fun
yeah you forget as an adult yeah I do
kind of feel like I can crafts man
Express Yourself
very therapeutic oh my God
well in second place is actually Zach
thank you very much I thought I was
gonna be dead last so thank you everyone
I do appreciate that no man yours is
[ __ ] up what what like gets
what about it bro it's so [ __ ]
it's just freaky dude I freaked out I
had an extra Central Drive when I looked
at it oh did you
I'm very much into the Macabre in horror
so
there you go let me take a look at this
[Laughter]
I mean why why did you why did you paint
it all like terrified well honestly I I
kind of [ __ ] up if I'm being honest I
scored the hair you know like you can
see it's kind of got grooves in it and I
just kind of overdid it on the beard
um yeah no kidding yeah
um but some a lot of people some people
said it looked like Gary kinda
hmm garyvee no your dad
Gary k
I can't say I see it but maybe it's
there maybe I see it or Ian said like
Homer Simpson mixed with like a sex doll
or something I don't know yeah it's
giving off a sex doll Vibe the mouth and
then uh third place
the Wally uh Wally pee
which was great technically beautiful
uh you know
it's okay followed by Olivia Sam Lena a
b
and Dan
this one is really yeah
oh heavy too well I use a lot of clay in
this
because you wow cam ladies and gentlemen
lots of clay
fantastic job camera yeah I don't like
sculpting I really don't but
it was fun to hang out with everybody
I I gotta say like
we all use the same photo and they're
all so unique and I was blown away I was
so impressed I loved something about
every single one all right everyone it's
so good I do think Ethan lives in every
single one of those heads dude it's
[ __ ] me up it's scary it's actually
[ __ ] me up
laughs
golly I love it such a cool thing I love
the yeah Sam's like little goosel oh
yeah that one was that one was very very
good the neck flap from the side is so
bad
it's fun it's funny yeah
um
somebody suggested Alexander thank you
for the gifted
says the next art project should be
Howie Mandel's
no Tick Tock ow
please now Lena gave me prolapse oh yeah
yeah yeah I noticed that not on purpose
wow someone said in chat put beanies on
them
that would look
correct obviously I don't know what to
say I'm just yeah I'm shocked you guys
all did amazing this is mind-bending
incredible stuff
well done everybody
she now we gotta put these somewhere to
haunt me every time I come in here
well
congratulations to everybody
and Ian especially there it is congrats
again congrats Zach I I had tears in my
eyes when everyone was looking at them
bro beautiful
I had I swear I was literally speechless
I'll take that as a compliment thank you
very much laughs
all right Bradley responded somebody
said Bradley's responded already are we
doing this live
all right Bradley what'd you say to me
he tried we'll do it right he wants to
do a zoom I want to do in person I don't
bite
no come on in person what are you
talking about
why because he's not backs or something
I mean I don't when did we try it I
think last time when you were talking
about having a mon you said let's do
soon yeah originally we said Zoom that
was in the um height of covet probably
I'll just I'm going to respond come to
our studio let's do it in person
Bradley my man
including the video
leading up to it
yeah I was gonna say aren't you guys
glad we didn't scrap that turned out I
mean it was a great segment we've been
ashamed to scrap it because of the bad
odd yeah no it was totally watchable
well they wanted to throw it out oh my
God no don't do that it's so good it was
great this is good [ __ ] yeah
um wow I'm kind of I
I just want to say I did not I genuinely
did not know who any of those people
were in the museum that's incredible
crazy
okay that one looked exactly like
Whitney Cummings it was blonde literally
did no it didn't it literally looked
exactly like her confusion or something
no I'm I'm the most like offline online
person there is like you don't know what
movies I don't watch anything that's
okay wait wait wait let me let me test
you and be honest with you but you
probably know everybody from Bachelor I
do that is what I watch that's it I'm
right away with you Sam I don't know any
of these people either okay hold the
phone okay who's this who's this who's
this
foreign
who's this
well well the Nate here yeah
[Music]
well he was okay well that was that's uh
what um
he was one of okay he was one of the
statues yeah yeah
it was also up Samuel Jackson okay bro
okay wait wait let me let me keep trying
because this is really interesting
this is actually super interesting for
me okay let's I'm gonna try some really
easy ones okay
okay
I mean I know some people okay
wait I'll tell you when I put it up uh
yeah
okay go ahead who's this
you don't know who that is
[Laughter]
um you can't be serious
you don't know who that is
I thought I didn't know anybody okay I
think okay I think I know
who he is now but you should I wish
exactly remind for who you who I was
thinking first who were you thinking
first I was thinking uh Baldwin like oh
[ __ ] yeah that's who I was thinking okay
who is it then it's Arnold okay good
okay okay
I gotta say the sound bite did kind of
help yeah oh yeah oh okay well wait I'm
gonna keep going because this is this is
super interesting here okay let's see
here here's a big movie star that's in
every movie right now
okay go ahead in
she's gonna know this one she is
okay obviously is this a dream boat okay
this is Dreamboat says okay let me mix
it up here a little bit that's your
dream boat what about
um
like in France like early 2000 movies
she didn't know who this was which I'm a
tester again see if she remembers
okay go ahead
I remember his statue you don't know who
that is did I not get that one right you
didn't it was Guillermo from Jimmy
Kimmel Guillermo
oh that one's good ab I'll do that one
another one
looks like Trevor from GTA
okay I don't know his name but he's from
The Shining okay GTA guy okay Jack
Nichols that's true okay that's a movie
I've seen at least you you recognize
here's a good one that AV suggested
okay okay there I have a couple of I'm
getting lots of suggestions
this one comes from Ab
go ahead
I have no idea who that is oh my God
that is so interesting he was in the
museum
I don't know I don't remember that one
Robert De Niro
okay whoa I'll take it wow
okay well I can say like Sam when I was
editing the thing she's like people are
gonna think I'm doing shtick like I that
no he will not watch movies we don't
watch anything she doesn't yeah she's
very unplugged
that's real interesting who do you know
who this is says Sam
um she looks like Millie Bobby Brown
grown up
I see the resemblance yeah a lot of
people do bro really yeah they do
compare them
um
I really I don't know
are you confused a lot of time on the
show when we're talking about oh yeah I
have to I have to Google people
constantly whoa this is Natalie Portman
the guy that Ryan Kavanaugh's yeah and
somebody was a girl oh the girl that
Brian Kavanaugh is obsessed with I have
an inappropriate relationship with a 40
year old Natalie Portman
dude this is super interesting
um bash Nation though okay yeah so here
oh no so who so who's this uh uh Sam
tester
[ __ ] yeah who's this
that's not batch nation that looks like
that's someone from Real Housewives yeah
oh you said that oh yeah that's not a
real housewife or an imagination thing
give me a bachelor Nation face
Ela had one she wanted to test you on
okay Sam who's this and hold on Ian wait
a second
okay let me just zoom in here
okay go ahead
Sam who is this
the face you want another photo yeah I
need here's a modern day photo man
you recognize him
no wow
no no I I would have I don't even know
who that is you don't know who Bill
Murray I would have never guessed is
this blowing anyone else's mind I tried
to put on Ghostbusters once she said it
was too crunchy and old crunchy yeah I
mean I get that but still Bill Murray
what about like he's been in so many
other great modern movies what is he
what has he been in maybe I've seen
something else much more Royal
Tenenbaums he's been a bunch of those
movies Groundhog's Day Groundhog Day
I think you would love the Royal ten
unbounds you should try to watch that
yeah yeah you saw a great movie
French dispatch I did see that yeah
using that oh okay I like that movie oh
who's like the most okay I'm just gonna
throw you like the easiest [ __ ] okay and
let's see if you can get it
this from our generation should be like
easy right Dan yeah this is like come on
everybody knows this face
[Music]
right
I think it's Bruce Willis okay
we found Mr Universal we got one that
him I know all right Bruce all right
there you go Brucie black
uh great name he's got there
you know Samuel Jackson who you didn't
know is apparently been in more movies
than anybody in the history of uh really
Cinema yeah I bet I have never seen a
movie with him in it
about someone mixing him up with someone
and that was in The Matrix and I think
we talked about it on the show Florence
fishberg okay by the way who's this Sam
this is Bachelor Nation
yeah okay there you go so she got we've
entered wait what's his last name Weber
I didn't even know he's last name all
right here's a super famous uh
he's a super famous actor
Samuel Jackson's so famous my Alexa
voice is Samuel Jackson I just
remembered
I say hey Samuel and answers in his
voice
you're Alexa yeah
he's everywhere that's right they do do
that this is like a super fun segment we
have to do this more Sam this is so
interesting I would love to yeah put
together people and see if you know them
how famous are you really does Sam know
who you are for real that has to be it
that's yeah do we know who this is Sam
that's some old man I don't know
wait wait wait wait
is he from Taken
um
[Applause]
oh I I don't know I had never seen him
before either oh really too bad about it
okay maybe there's Al Pacino the
greatest actor ever lived I give up Al
pacquino I think this is becoming an age
thing well okay I mean Al Pacino okay
I haven't known any okay let me just
give you like the most obvious easy like
okay everyone knows who this is
okay right Eli I mean come on
wait hold on hold on don't show it shows
his uh name I don't know why
literally all of these have been showing
their name I think it's too far away for
her to see
but every single image that we've held
up you can see the name in the URL
uh mom don't look at the URL how do I
just open it bro right click open image
in new tab
all right go ahead Sam who's this
okay that's Brad Pitt there you go okay
there you go that one's like super easy
right that's easy that's an easy one
okay so there are people in the chat
saying they're like 22 24 and and they
did know everyone
okay here's a really that's funny to
think maybe we're just getting old
why I know all the young people too
okay here's an interesting one this this
one is going to be interesting well
there's a few saying I don't know any of
these what
you guys got to go back and watch your
your classics
are they really even Classics I mean
they're still modern days and I'm not
asking to go watch Citizen Kane okay
Boomer
you know what I mean all right Sam who's
this
[Music]
okay okay there you go he was he was he
was very famous for that Robin Williams
King absolutely it's not your fault
um okay name all four of these uh Sam
Let's test your your Savvy here on
Bachelor in Paradise
is Michael Serene Brandon and oh [ __ ]
um
I really like her but I can't place her
name right now
still super impressive you did three I'm
watching Bachelor in Paradise what's her
name I don't know any of them I don't
know I cannot Place her name I don't I
like her though yeah but I don't know by
the way you Bachelor in Paradise pretty
good right so good I feel good I'm like
so good bachelor and bachelorette at
this point is just a lead up to Bachelor
in Paradise those shows I know suck yeah
I just live for Bachelor in Paradise
it's everything to me
okay
I guess okay okay this one this one
you should get but let's see go ahead
yeah
[Music]
you guys come on sorry to re-traumatize
you like that Sonic Sonic the Hedgehog
of course
okay that okay
this is a good one this is a good one
see I'm here we'll wrap it up here soon
go ahead
[Music]
oh come on you gotta know this
you don't know I don't know
what if they what have they been in
every track wait you said this at the
Museum too was it um
what'd you talk about donkey Oh Daddy
Daycare
what I've never seen that I have seen
Frank though
is it he's donkey he's donkey
some say
[Applause]
I was hearing whispers yeah
holy smokes yeah we got weights and fish
back here hey hey
all right one more one more for the road
let's see
get a lady people are saying
okay
say again
but I think that okay go ahead
oh yeah she gotta know that one right
she's got to know that one
everybody knows that
here it is Sam
for your consideration
that's Miss Angelina oh there it is
[Music]
okay one more
too much fun
it's like a party trick it is it's so
interesting too much wine sorry
okay who's this
[Laughter]
like obviously that's Whitney okay all
right but the statue looked exactly like
her okay well then let me test you in a
different way
um
what's her name [ __ ]
[Music]
I remember thank you Ian
this one is very rare popular
I'll give you a hint it is not
uh Whitney Cummings
[Music]
that's Scarlett Johansson oh there you
go there you go okay well there it is uh
we a new segment unlocked super
interesting stuff huh
love that I'm excited to put people
together
super fun
all right good stuff eh on this Friday
Friday evening fun stuff today
who is Sam
the question we all asked from time to
time
oh thank you for the 50 gifted
um
who's Sam
Saudi benefactor
thank you yeah so we'll have a Tuesday
episode up for members remember
every Tuesday remember is the see you
next Tuesday
members only podcast
um we should think of a fun topic we'll
also have an episode on Monday right
yeah of course okay yeah you just made
it sound like that was going to be the
last episode yeah you're right I'm gonna
film it I usually film them on Sunday so
I was wondering do you guys have any
suggestions for topics for uh see you
next Tuesday
did you guys set up anything where they
can leave questions or stuff like that
yeah I'd love to do FAQs that'd be fun
uh we can
either create a Reddit thread for that
or on the Discord would be
um could it be like a q a kind of thing
too much what about motivational
inspirational life quotes with Ethan
Klein
I will give you my free course that will
guarantee wealth and success all you
have to do is follow these easy steps
people are just saying uh talk about
Housewives Bachelor I think that show
should is just going to become reality
show Talk podcast we just watched last
night
it was a great great episode of Salt
Lake City and then um the first part of
Beverly Hills reunion
it's too motivational I'm gonna motivate
you guys okay
get in the mood we are going to achieve
we are going to succeed we are going to
out V Gary Vee
we're gonna Crush garyvee
we're gonna sell some nfts nice
we're going to lose all of our money in
crypto hell yeah
and uh
yeah be a strawberry
okay
can I uh can I say something real quick
um Troubadour is sold out so I want to
thank you guys so much for everything
there it is Zach at the Troubadour I
just hold on I couldn't lie without you
guys so I mean amazing so thank you all
there on the 16th no the 30th
January I'll be there on the 16th all
right that's great but there's not gonna
be a concert that age well I got it
who's playing the trooper on the 16th
because that's when I'm gonna be there
let's see
anyways thank you guys so much
congratulations thank you
congratulations so cool that's huge yeah
he's from shredding that [ __ ] up yeah
all right guys well have a great weekend
uh had a fun episode here spending with
you guys
Friday baby
back on Monday as always with another
action-packed mother loving I just gotta
answer all right ELO are you Tim
garcelle of course I'm Tim grossell yeah
it's garcelle garcelle and Sutton for
Life yeah if you're not team garcelle
and Sutton you're something's wrong with
you
you're basically
Erica there's like one person it's Erica
I guess Lisa Renna got booed at some
Bravo con or something like that really
yeah oh I need links
I [ __ ] hate her
I'm trying to catch up on a real
housewife lore yeah I have to download
peacock yes yeah it is so horrible bro
we're paying for people now
they got you um I'm getting my money's
worth because I'm watching all the
housewives and I'm into below deck and
that's on people well that's a great
show dude we're canceling our our cable
really everything else I didn't even get
cable in my apartment it sucks yeah me
either well a couple years ago we're
like you know what it'd be fun to try it
because we never had it either it's yeah
[ __ ] horrible and now with all the
apps you don't even need it it's really
a buggy like things don't work all the
time
yeah well I guess I am going to be
downloading peacock so yeah I think it's
like six bucks a month or something it's
not that bad I don't think but there's
insane content on there if you like
reality shows yeah were you at Bravo
it's just a day after but at least like
no ads yeah below the deck is absurdly
entertaining the food that one is really
good
is that the
is that a Star Trek show no what the
[ __ ] is below the deck
that does not fit into this conversation
isn't there there's some Star Trek
cartoon I haven't seen it but isn't
there some Star Trek show that's called
uh
below deck is oh it's called Lower decks
uh yeah I wasn't that wasn't coming out
of the blue I haven't seen it but I was
just gonna watch below deck okay got it
yeah it's about you a crew that works on
a charter yacht oh okay that kind of
okay Ali would like that an actual deck
yeah
so good interesting
wait whoa whoa what Chef Ben that's the
guy we like right what about him oh
someone just said he's the man I thought
someone was being like I'm Chef Ben I
need a meal from that guy all right
listen have a great weekend everybody uh
we'll see you be back on Monday
to have another week together so there
it is
thanks for being with us this week huh
forget about it forget about it have a
great week Chad is saying lower decks is
really good so maybe I will check that
out now though
I'm gonna check out all the decks people
two decks down yeah
Tata
bye guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]